hey guys do you like charity
gamers we have a big announcement we are
going to be doing a 24-hour charity
stream you heard that right so the world
situation kind of messed up right now
for all sorts of different reasons so we
thought we would come together stream
for 24 hours to support doctors without
borders on our twitch channel twitch.tv
slash trash taste podcast what are we
going to be doing on that stream though
is the question you're probably asking
games
we have a bunch of different things
planned including guests games and
humiliation and joan will eat a ghost
pepper maybe who knows if we maybe
maybe so make sure to open up that
wallet to make sure that joey can suffer
that's that's the reason we're doing it
i'm not here for the charity i'm here to
make joey suffer
so the event will be starting 11 a.m
japan time on the 19th of march uh if
you live anywhere else in the world here
are some just basic time zones that
hopefully mood is putting on screen
right now if not look it up yourself on
time converter but yeah it'll be going
on 24 hours and uh we'll hopefully
change the world for the better even for
a little bit and on with the episode
oh what why did you have to do that on
the mic why not pretty sure that's how
down with the sickness stuff yeah yeah
oh we don't get caught
you can't right not for that i was too
perfect in my
impression of disturbed
welcome to this episode of trash taste
and today we're going to be comparing
our musical tastes our trash taste in
music or good taste who knows maybe one
of us has good taste in music
i've said no one watching this
unfortunately we can't plead the fifth
in trash taste episodes which i would
love to do because i don't really know
how to describe music very well okay
well establish that very early on
yeah see we've established that with
connor but uh i also have been [ __ ]
myself with the thought of this episode
and especially when it came to like
picking my choices one it was super
difficult because i didn't know like
i didn't know how to describe why
i liked like the pics that i picked i
just know that they were important to me
at a time in mind you got to see why we
like it [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
i guess like on what basis did you pick
it because it's like i guess gone was
saying that like it was an important
like important artist in your life right
yeah mine is also kind of based on that
in a sense
yeah
okay actually first question how did you
boys what what uh what
what method did you use to like pick
your artists i don't know i don't know
song songs sound good i put down yeah
connor's like connor's missing do i
remember the artist's name i'll put it
down yeah yeah yeah because actually
like
my biggest difficulty right is that i
like a lot of songs
but i don't know if i like a lot of
artists you know like i like like i like
certain songs from certain artists but
like i i feel like i'm more like i get
into genres of music or like i get into
like a certain genre then more than i
get into this one specific artist or
this one specific band and if i do it's
like very very very rare
i think that's pretty normal it's like
food you know it's like i like french
food i don't like all french food yeah
yeah so it's like
that's the way i see it but i do like
all mexican food it's pretty [ __ ]
good yeah so i guess we'll see that's
kind of how i view it for me it was like
for me it was like i'll you know i
couldn't just like reach into the nether
and grab a band because i'm sure if i
did if i did that i'm sure there'd be
like a million other bands that i just
completely forgot about so i was like
all right i'll split it into genres so i
was like all right i like metal music
[ __ ]
that didn't make it any easier i'm like
like spongebob writing the my first
thought my first four picks i'm like so
confident like
this one oh that one okay oh this one
okay wait what else do i listen to
yeah i i literally went okay so you know
we had our first four or five picks that
was you know easy came to our head and
then like i went to my spotify to try
and see if i could narrow down anything
else that i could like talk about or was
important to me and the more i scrolled
more i'm just like what the [ __ ] is my
music taste what what is actually this
like collection of songs that i've put
together that defines who i am i like i
try to psychoanalyze this and i'm like i
don't know what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
that's what i love about doing these
three by three episodes is that more so
than our audience trying to figure out
what our tastes are we find out what our
own tastes are like i already want to
change some of my picks but we'll go
with it
well some of my picks were like i chose
one band but it was more of just like i
wanted to pick one band just to just
just to talk about talk about
several bands that i want yeah
get those excuses out now yeah yeah yeah
get them out set them up
oh yeah this one this was that often
that one time that i saved he loved this
song and i i also love it
yeah i don't know i guess i guess it's
been it's like now that i think about it
i have like such a different
relationship to music than i do to like
other forms of media you know like i
have like really games that i could talk
about forever about like why i really
[ __ ] like this game same thing with
movies same thing with anime obviously
but but like with music's always been
this one enigma for me because music's
just been this one thing where i like
certain things i don't know why i like
it i just like it it's because most
people when they listen to music
i just like it no explanation
sorry
i think it's just because like most
people when they listen to music don't
think that deeply about what they're
listening to like there isn't a guy that
like runs into the room and it's like
explain what you're listening to right
now it's like ah
the drums are good yeah yeah
when someone's like what's your taste in
music you can just be like ah
metal you know you don't listen yeah
yeah and then it was like okay
that's it right yeah like when people
ask me what am i tasting music is i'm
just like ah
yes yes i like socks i like everything i
like like i like songs i hate i hate
being that guy who just goes i like a
bit of everything
it's just like the generic answer but i
really literally don't know how to
answer that question aside from yeah i
like a bit of everything should i should
we stop giving excuses to ourselves
this is it are we going to do trash box
going yeah bringing back trash
tradition yes all right so i guess i
don't want joey to go first
i don't want to go first either because
i don't want i don't want to follow joey
i don't want to have joey
like
give him this his [ __ ] presentation
his powerpoint with animations you know
why he likes my metallica
my goal for this uh episode is to not be
that pretentious music we need you to be
that protection i don't want to be that
prediction because because you need to
like counteract me and conor going
i like the beeps and the boobs and i'm
being like well the the voice sounded
nice i like the voice and i'm just like
i like the voice
oh it's it's called corner first okay
perfect all right this is gonna be tough
all right
this is like my mom's gonna walk in and
there's just [ __ ] everywhere and i'm
like
listen i can explain
this has a reason
this is a weird three by three i think
yeah some of them you'll expect some of
them you won't also i chose i tried to
choose a funny image for some of them i
can think of at least
three bands that's good that's good yeah
actually can you really yeah i thought
only one
no no there's at least think of
definitely one
no i can i could think of at least three
all right we'll find out all right let's
find out
the image i chose for the weekend
where did you get the image of the
weekend that's like a famous picture
this is a weird one okay yeah i got i
got the three that i thought oh okay
yeah yeah that's good what was the three
that you thought i knew daft punk
weakened and taming power that's right i
knew he was going to put that on which
jerry knows i love taylor and paula yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh
okay bo burnham on the left yeah i got
probably burn i'm gonna get one oh okay
oh yeah yeah yeah uh
that shouldn't surprise you do you know
this is kind of like we'll get into this
yeah right
this is more about city pop in general
i don't think i know the rest
uh this is uh parcels
castles yeah so they're kind of not well
known but it's very similar vibes to
daft punk plus this is a breakbot over
there you know breakbot you don't know
you know breakbot i know their song
though you know the the baby i'm yours
the the ladies and gentlemen we got him
song oh that's that's breakpoint that's
breakbot okay the rest of their songs
are amazing okay i've listened to some
of their music like their songs [ __ ]
slap yeah i don't know if i know them
you know that you you've definitely
heard them no you know the meme song
probably
okay
no no have you ever listened to that
song without it being bass booster
i only know that song
okay so i mean there's not much i guess
the band i listen to the most it's
definitely these five are the ones i
listen to right now yeah right i love
the weekend yeah so you also dropped the
new album and i i [ __ ] love that
album that's a great album i guess who
do i want to talk about first who should
i talk about who do you want um that's i
guess you've talked about who's the
parcels
yeah yeah let's talk about parcels
because i don't think gone right so
they're a band right now i believe okay
okay this is going to be hard to talk
about because i don't know a lot about a
lot of these people all i know is that i
play their music an awful lot i think
they're a band
that is based in germany i don't think
they are german okay but they live in
germany and they do kind of like
it's very like funk but also oh how do i
describe music to people i only know
people because like the guy the guy in
like i can literally see connor's like
brain cells committing suicide as he's
like trying to process this because i'm
not gonna lie like i looked at this
picture of parcels and the guy at the
back in the middle looks like george
harrison yeah he's weird right yeah they
look like beetles if they were around
today i don't know how to explain it
it's like they don't
i don't know uh parcels are an
australian electoral pop oh they're
always like these aussies there we go oh
okay okay
electric
electro pop there we go
you know a lot of the things you can see
like the influence of like if you look
daft punk in the middle kind of like
little parts of death panic they've
experimented in yeah that's probably
where i like because it's like i think
my favorite uh def punk album is like
discovery which i've put there yeah but
i don't think there's many songs in
death point i don't like right even the
first album is probably the one i don't
like the most because it's very like
more experimental as opposed to the
other stuff they did yeah it's a lot
more like rudimentary for sure and a lot
of some of the songs in the first album
i cannot remember the name of the first
album the one with the am on the front
of it literally i think it might just be
yeah i mean i feel like i only started
listening to darth park after like was
it the homework album
homework was the first one where i
properly got into dark punk as well i
think that's where most people got into
the dark part like yeah the homework or
discovery well i think it was like was i
think the first big hit was around the
world wasn't it yeah yeah that was that
was like what put them on the map which
is the most repetitive song in existence
yeah what's it what's the album you have
to fact check me on a lot of this we're
going to need a lot of fractures yeah
everyone behind the camera
we need like seven fact checkers right
now
collaborating with dark punk on their
2017's single or not i didn't even know
that oh there you go that's that's
probably where that's probably where why
because a lot of these artists that i
find that i've no idea who they are it's
like youtube recommends me yeah you know
who i'm surprised is not on your three
by three joji jojo i don't listen to
joji that much every time i go to your
house you're playing joji that is true
that is true i've played a lot of i
think i had faces of joji like i like
joji a lot you know like i like joji a
lot but that just sounds like a band
i love joji's music but there's only
like four songs that i actually listen
to the rest of the album i don't really
like i think at least for the first five
i've listened to like everything from
tame impala weekend death punk breakbot
yeah uh parcels i've listened to like
everything and like so the parcels def
punk and breakbot i can just put on
their albums yeah yeah any any song and
i'll have a good time and i'm like this
is great like if i'm in a car those are
the three i'm playing so this is all
like recent taste then or as within the
past five years unfortunately my my
tastes haven't really changed much in
the past six years it's kind of like i
have phases where i go into something
else but always comes back to that type
of music what did you listen to when you
were a kid yeah that's a good question
well right in the bottom uh bottom right
is biffy clara jebe claro no idea no
idea who i don't know but that album
cover is cool right yeah
i said before is a scottish rock band
yeah okay um and
uh they've done they've done us this
thing
scottish they've supported for foo
fighters a few times oh okay so you like
foo fighters yeah and you want a more
scottish version of foo fighters
i might be butchering and doing an
absolute disservice to buffy clark but i
like foo fighters a lot and the way i
found them is that a lot of my friends
in school really liked food fighters and
were when we were growing up that's the
stuff they liked and then i got into
biffy clara from there and i went to
watch them live that was the first
concert i ever went to a biffy clara
concert yeah it was amazing i loved it
so much and uh i don't know i would say
uh this is a good album to listen to
they had the really famous one that came
out before this i can't remember the
name of it it's got like two big colors
on the front of it
got the name of it did they do they sing
it like a scottish accent as well yeah
so that's what i love about them like
you know sometimes a lot of bands where
they're like from scotland but they just
sound american somehow yeah yeah but
it's like
so it was that first
that's what i want more bands to do
though because like the one thing like
seeing in the accent of the country that
they're from you should yeah i think
you'd quite like biffy that's what i
love about life that's what i love about
like proclaimers right because like when
they sing the 500 mile song they
couldn't sound any more [ __ ] scottish
than that song
i find it so weird when i like hear an
artist right and you hear you hear them
sing right and then you hear them speak
and there is like such a dissonance
between how they sing and how they speak
i remember one of the first time i heard
adele speak right and it's like the most
northern accents you're british
why are you surprised you're british
because like she doesn't sound like
anything like that when she sings
probably for good reason
could you imagine an adele song in the
accent that she's facing like like
there's no way she would have blown up
because no one would have been able to
understand what she was through the rain
for like
four adele getting dragged running in
the deep
rolling in the deep eye out
she wouldn't have popped off i'm sorry
because like cause like i had i had no
idea she was uh she was british until
until i heard her speak and she was then
i was like oh this is
the most northern person i've ever heard
speak in my life and i feel a lot of
australian artists are like that too
like sia for example is like the most
australian sound
interviews but when she sings everyone
thinks
damn we like lose our accents for some
reason i don't know why yeah like we
can't get like i i find it hard to i
guess do an accent but it's not hard for
some reason it's less hard to sing an
accent i don't know it's yeah it's weird
right that's i find it easier to sing in
an american accent than i do speak in an
american accent i don't understand at
all
how it works
i know how accents were i don't know i
don't know how it works when you sing
though yeah different register i think
that's that's why when i hear an accent
in a song i it immediately like just
sticks out to me i guess because you
always hear like the neutral american
accent with like a lot of songs so yeah
when you hear an accent that is just
anything that's not like the
stereotypical neutral american accent it
immediately just sticks out in my mind
yeah yeah yeah that's what that's what i
want more artists to do though because
like otherwise like everyone's just
gonna sound the [ __ ] same right and
it's like if if there's the best way to
make you as an artist stand out is to
just sound different like just just sing
in a different accent because then
immediately you'll be like you'll listen
to a beefy clara song and you'll be like
oh they sound scottish it must be a
beefy clarissa yeah i mean they're very
very scottish when you hear them right
it's fun could you imagine if beefy
claire like obviously i don't know
before right but you said they kind of
sound similar to foo fighters oh well
i'd say it's kind of in the same vein
it's uh like kind of feeling of the way
they say so would you say that if po
chance the biffy clara lead singer
like dave grohl then it would sound like
foo fighters or no no i don't know it's
weird because the songs are so scottish
like big massive fans massive
fans are like
that's the only way that i know because
i'm i don't understand how to talk about
music like a normal human being yeah so
there's any way i can imagine explaining
it uh but also it was like the only the
first album like i ever bought out of
like like physical i think i only ever
bought like three albums in my life
right right and i think this was the
first one oh i don't know
another thing about i don't think i've
ever bought an album i love this so much
i remember i loaded it onto my pc
i don't know i put it on my xbox yeah
yeah and you could play the albums on
xbox while playing another game
i would open up that [ __ ]
menu the [ __ ] big one
the volume was just dreadfully like not
managed correctly so i was playing
modern warfare
i had a cd player like the [ __ ] like
chunky i had one of those two yeah yeah
you know what's the first album i bought
on cd what [ __ ] simple plan
classic joke that album slaps i don't
care what anyone says
man but yeah i have a tamer impala as
well i love tame impala my favorite
album is the slow rush not the other one
that everyone uh that you see everywhere
and everyone talks about
i love slow rush breathe deeper is like
my favorite song for damon paul i love
that [ __ ] song
i don't know driving to tame impala is
like
another level of enjoying it i don't
know why have you listened to his side
project pawned no
if you liked him paul you'll learn that
it's probably pretty well it's just tame
and power but harder will you recommend
it to me i'll find out probably not
basically that's how my music is decided
yeah
have the algorithm gods decided
if so yes i'll listen but unfortunately
sometimes it recommends me uh
artists there's like one song i really
like and i check out the other stuff and
i'm like wow yeah there's lots of
honestly if that happens like that who
is the one on the left above bo burnham
oh this is uh you know them uh snails
house oh snap oh is that snail's house
yeah i love it
no lyrics let's go yeah i didn't i
didn't recognize the art yeah i love
snails house uh it's probably like
if i can encapsulate all my i guess i
don't even if it's a disservice to call
it weeby music it's kind of like it's it
is nostalgic
it's a subculture of like weeby he's
half japanese
yeah like we be
i like nerdy this one makes me feel i
like this one yeah it's good i i there
was a phase there was a phase in my life
where i feel like i listened to how does
it make you feel happy i want to say
happy emotions so there was like before
i moved to japan i want to say i
listened to this for like god like a
whole year straight
were you prepping your japan to visit
with somebody
before i even started the movie
and then weirdly it was like yeah i just
love this album a lot not that i'm sorry
i love all of his songs yeah uh absolute
all bangers all kind of different moods
even though like it's the same style
yeah i like how it it doesn't always
feel the same there's a bunch of
variations shout out to snell's house
banging if you like anime music or
anything like that or like electronic
you'll probably like this it's really
good yeah i call i call this genre weeb
core
weebcore
it's like it's it's weeb daft punk yeah
question mark i don't know there's no
there's no lyrics that's such a good
name for it it is a weapon it's weird
it feels like
a roller coaster you're on
that you you're not on it you're not on
it but you're right
how the [ __ ] do i describe music how do
you do this
how does anthony fantano do this what
the [ __ ] is he doing
to say a lot of adjectives
words
this is like how i describe this music
it's like it's like if you go to an
artist
if you go to an artist alley in any
convention and put that and take that
experience put that in the genre of
music that is like that's
that feeling before you go to a
convention
obviously not now because you're
miserable adults but yeah you know a few
earlier a few years earlier when you're
like kind of excited you're like bubbly
you're like oh yeah it's so exciting
that's the feeling like [ __ ] shoved
it into a job that i can just like
anytime i want i can just take it
out snail's house to me is like what it
must sound like to live in the kirby
universe yes
that's what it sounds like to me it's
like [ __ ] your enemies come up yeah
everything is like everything everything
is like
a good sock on everything it's like
everything is like round and like bubbly
and pastel colored and like overly happy
i could fall over but the floor is made
of marshmallows
yeah it's just like it's pillowy yeah
dude it's great yeah it's such a great
if you wanna if you wanna be you know
feel happy and have a good time and you
you wanna feel vibes try snail's house
and you don't lyrics because i'm
honestly sometimes like should get in
the way sometimes
no i do sometimes i just sometimes
someone who doesn't even listen to
lyrics i feel something missing without
vocal tracking we could talk about that
we can talk about other pictures that we
can
i love the weekend and this is a weird
one because i for very long very very
long time just kind of felt indifferent
towards the weekend i felt like it was
that artist that just always got like
number ones but like right you know it's
kind of like yeah whatever but then like
the last album came out and i was like
okay no no this is all fire this is all
like really [ __ ] good okay i think
he's actually like insane and then i
went back and listened to the other
stuff i i appreciated it way more now
yeah
seeing how far he's grown and how how
much his albums have like just improved
no i'm definitely i was definitely the
same i was like oh this is just like
another the generic pop guy there's
another
figure exactly exactly and because like
when i listen to house of balloons which
is his first album i was like oh this is
like it's good but it's like nothing
special and then after hours came out
with like blinding lights like that
album i was like okay okay i see you i
see it and then the new album was like
all right solidified you're pretty good
dude this this album it's been like out
for like i don't know like two months at
this point and i've literally just
listened to that album non-stop it's so
good i think the weekend actually is
right now the most streamed artist on
spotify it wouldn't be number one right
now like this album has
so many bangers that like it's it's so
fun talking about this album to people
because everyone i spoke to has a
different favorite song yeah it's not
like other albums where it's like okay
everyone likes uh ex-song the most and
it's very predictable it's like everyone
is just telling me about other songs
they like them
yeah that one is a banger that's that's
the best kind of artist though right
where it's like
it's like you can't pick like a top like
i would think it's really difficult for
someone like the weekend to make like a
greatest hits album yeah because it's
like which songs do we not put in that
album right true because every song is
great also i love that like i wasn't
paying attention to lyrics but then i
started actually paying attention to the
lyrics this current album i'm like [ __ ]
man this is really [ __ ] sad yeah
like what's going on with this man he's
like yeah i've got to see a woman she's
[ __ ] another man
she's like i'm so sad that she's [ __ ]
another man and it's like what
what
he's like i loved her and then she
stepped on my heart and i'm like whoa
while an 80s like funk basically
oh
how often do you listen to like music
lyrics in
songs
so what made you listen to the lyrics in
this song
so many times after a point i started
like
he would say stuff and i was like hold
up
[Laughter]
yeah exactly and bo burnham you know bo
burnham was one of those things where
you kind of have to listen to the lyrics
to enjoy the music
and it really made me
see that like okay because to me
comedy music before was like just uh
[ __ ] lonely island yeah yeah like
weirdo younger thing but not really yeah
yeah i mean it's it was like parody
music yeah where they were kind of for
me it would like they would take a song
or like an established like genre of
music and just kind of like parody that
um on like a surface level if that makes
sense and and tim mentioned it's
obviously very everyone always loves him
yeah yeah but like even that that music
i wasn't like super into but i don't
know when i when i said i've watched by
burnham specials like uh all of them
like at least four plus times now and i
just love it to death yeah and i really
like the songs they're really funny but
also really good some of them are like
absolute bangers yeah yeah um i love the
one at the end of uh make happy for the
one where it is but it's when he's
talking about burritos and putting the
hand in the pringle
[Music]
sounds like something you'd really need
but it's so good though because it's
like it starts off as a joke and then it
turns into this whole you know the
struggle of being a creator and what
people expect things from you and how do
you struggle with that you know and as
uh as somebody who creates stuff it was
like oh [ __ ] whoa this is [ __ ] well
this is weird yeah did you ever like get
into lonely island though back in the
day i loved lonely island when i was
like 14 i thought this [ __ ] was like
peak comedy and music and i was like i
was like oh my god he threw it on the
ground oh my dude oh my god he put a
dick in a box like what the [ __ ]
this show he's talking about
yeah
damn man this song is about three sons
you know like you know because i was a
kid and i thought she was hilarious like
yeah i just had sex i thought that was
like the peak comedy
for me it was like i'm on a boat
and he just had t-pain in there for no
[ __ ] reason it was it was that and
like a boss yeah like a boss
those were like the most viewed [ __ ]
videos on youtube yeah yeah yeah and
they were like i i literally i remember
because i have this weird memory of me
playing black ops one and just playing
lonely island songs on repeat while i'm
playing and i literally did nothing but
listen to the little thing everyone was
like that in the early stages though it
was like bro burnham is like it kind of
took the best of like comedy and then
added it with like amazing funny uh
stand up with amazing lyrics and great
and i love the song
it's like one minute long it's the
[ __ ] jeff bezos song from inside i
[ __ ] love that one you've got to
listen to it because i'm sorry i've only
seen inside but like obviously it's one
of the few artists where i did listen to
the songs because he is like i guess i
don't know how you'd categorize or put
like how do you categorize these kind of
songs but it's like it's like comedy
songs but it also like
it he's his songs also make you think
yeah yeah like the message kind of like
sticks with you it's funny and deep
the best of both
is it too deep for you i don't know but
uh it's the evangelion of comedy music
i'm kidding i'm kidding yeah i know i
want to put it on cause i wanted to talk
about it and i thought that it was
really interesting and uh you know
there's a lot of artists i could have
put on um like you could have put uh i
love pendulum
i wanted to see
i almost put pendulum i went to watch
pendulum live and it was probably like
the greatest
experience ever i nearly died like four
times being stepped on to death but
that's that must have been like audio
crack man dude it was insane so i went
to get on which pendulum it was in like
a warehouse like this concrete warehouse
yeah yeah and it was just like some kind
of like satanic ritual it looked like
because there was just this thing was so
tall yeah so you just see this massive
like hunk of concrete and then just
depends on just going hard on this yeah
yeah yeah yeah holy [ __ ] whenever when
tarantula came on that was insane
everyone went insane it was just like
i've never been in such a like
just intense atmosphere it was so funny
i don't normally like going to concerts
but that one was really fun because i
need the lyrics as well somehow
memory because i listen
that many lyrics to pendulum songs
i mean
uh yeah it's very easy everyone
remembers the opening to witchcraft yeah
yeah that's the one song everyone would
just start seeing it's like chiller yeah
i've been i've been listening to the
pendulum since i was like [ __ ] 12 and
i would listen to them they were pretty
inescapable back when yeah yeah blood
sugar yeah yeah i remember the product
nightmares as well
blood sugar was prodigy what am i
talking about yeah yeah it was like
pendulum and prodigy where they were
just like [ __ ] massive yeah i was
like they were inescapable at a point
where like i remember like they came out
as like the in the age where i just
started going clubbing and like you'd
hear a pendulum song and a prodigy song
at least once in every [ __ ] episode
but that i i said like pendulum was
definitely like my early inspiration
before i found like i started really
getting into like daft punk right yeah
obviously interstellar uh is amazing and
all the music videos just go so goddamn
well with the song and
not the movie the owl
not the soundtrack to the movie it's
amazing and then you got uh andy
yeah so this is just like city pop this
is the i can't stop loneliness song have
you heard that one yeah i [ __ ] love
that song i can't stop
the loneliness i don't know what i like
we're gonna get cop right quick
that's why i'm singing in bed i'm
singing
very
i love city pop um obviously i don't
know how to encapsulate all of city pop
i could just put plastic love and
quality paper you know i feel like city
pop has definitely blown up in the past
what four or five years it's going crazy
even the weekend on his new album
samples a lot of city park oh yeah and
it's so goddamn good it's like city pop
with like the vocals for god um it's
just amazing it's so good and yeah i
mean i absolutely adore city pop it
makes me nostalgic for that time that i
lived in japan in the 80s and yeah
stared out the window yeah definitely
and was in the bubble period it's a good
time
was it literally plastic love that
literally like kind of reinvigorated
this city pop friends that's like
happening so because yes
occasionally but i don't think anyone
the movement hadn't really taken off i
think plastic love is what really got
people into thinking about listening to
other songs because i definitely heard
silly uh city pop songs before this
right but never enough to make me be
like is this a genre yeah i don't know
what this is it was also just like such
a mystery as to why it was that song
that blew up like this i've seen like
documentaries on youtube about like why
did plastic love blow up and [ __ ] and
it's like because and i'm just like
because it's a good song
yeah i mean like nothing more also like
the youtube algorithm just works in
[ __ ] mysterious ways exactly yeah i
mean there's there's two ways i get
recommended songs it's memes
or youtube algorithm yeah honestly memes
is like a really underrated way to
discover new music because a lot
a lot of meme songs are actually like
good songs yeah you don't you forget
that they're good songs because you've
just heard it bass boosted so many times
maybe i'm yours is i honestly like a
[ __ ] amazing song and it's so [ __ ]
stupid that i can't listen to the song
without thinking of ladies and gentlemen
we got it
and follow me
it's awful
ruined my life no because i remember
when i heard first heard that song
he got recommended to me on youtube and
i was just like oh it's the meme song
and i was waiting for like the bass
boost to come in and then it just it
like it was just the song and i remember
thinking damn why did they bass boost
this [ __ ] masterpiece man
it's like taking the mona lisa and like
[ __ ] spitting on it you know
ironically like crap dan's song yeah
it's a good song and uh the shooting
star song remember that one oh that was
a good song
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know that one yeah that one was like
good actually
they're great songs all right well
that's my three by three uh go and check
some of them out you might like it if
you like daft punk you'll probably like
a lot of these i don't know
yeah you should try it yeah i love
parcels man some of those songs are so
[ __ ] good this episode is sponsored
by premium bandai usa premium bandai usa
is one of bandai's official online
stores that offers an extensive
ever-changing lineup of high quality and
limited run products pulled right out of
your favorite anime series right now as
a part of their special campaign they
are offering free shipping on all
digimon themed items until march 9th est
today premium bandai has sent us a
collection of their newest digimon items
to show off to you first of all garn is
wearing it right now a wearable digivice
also known as the vital bracelet digital
monster digivice v from the currently
airing digimon ghost game anime not only
does it monitor your heart rate and
count your steps but it also levels up
your digimon accordingly allow you to
battle other people's digimons it's like
having a digimon on the go that's such a
cool concept honestly like on like
having a fitness bracelet that also
levels up your digimon as you work out
dude weebs are finally going to be
working
they've also sent us a set of card
sleeves with matching play mats to give
you an idea of what two of their new
digimon card game items currently up for
pre-order look like irl wow check out
each of their designs on screen right
now i don't know did you gotta say it's
a nice sized playmat it is plenty of
playing it is go check out all the items
displayed on our table today and much
more on premium bandai usa during their
free shipping campaign by clicking the
link in the description below thanks
again to premium bandai usa for
sponsoring us today thanks the episode
all right well that's my uh initial
trash tasting music thank god that's out
there
before before we move on
obviously uh obviously you talked about
a lot of your music that you're into now
but like what i i'm curious what you
listen to as a kid like do you remember
or did you just not put any of them on
like as early as you can remember yeah
fighters uh
uh that was a big one biffy claro
uh pendulum
prodigy
then i had that weird phase where i was
like yeah calvin harris is really good
i i was actually like this close man
calvin harrison
racism
but like i would be lying if i'd like
didn't go through a phase where i
listened to a [ __ ] ton of calvin house
i'm not immune to [ __ ] taste right there
was a point where i listened to a lot a
lot of calvin harris did you listen to a
lot of david guetta as well oh god that
i did you know you know when you listen
to that uh swedish housemate airplanes
in the night sky song yeah you're like
how about i i just want all music that
sounds exactly like this yeah black ips
you know
when i have like no no [ __ ]
personality of my own i would just
listen to what the charts told me was
the billboards like yeah the billboards
top 20. i want to i want to fit in i
want to seem normal i'm going to say i
like this song i love that new calvin
harris song you know
i felt like i almost like listened to
that music just so i could have i could
keep up with what people are talking
about because i didn't want to get
bullied for liking like [ __ ] scottish
bands
well you know
like there was a lot of social pressure
yeah like me listening to calvin harris
was the equivalent of me watching
football matches so like i could have
something to talk about it's like oh
yeah you see uh that's true yeah yeah
you you see the latest match oh yeah the
new captain how the song came out that
was pretty good wasn't it but like i
feel like i never really had a defined
music taste because i was kind of you
know as well back then i had to
uh find a means to get a hold of it yeah
and that often was a big limiting factor
in what i could discover i did the
opposite i was like oh i listened to
that recent calvin harris song bit [ __ ]
in it
i've never seen it well you have good
tastes
it doesn't really matter
it matters to me
it's not going to matter
i see a t it's oh it's me there you go
you're saved i guess okay thank you
thank god joey can carry the podcast
after after i finish talking about okay
so
um so how i tried to pick this i tried
to pick this i tried to pick music
and artists and songs that really
defined every stage of my life so this
might be a little bit random are we
gonna see peppa pig the full album
what do
it was a cold summer night at the age of
three
i decided it was honestly yeah yeah
twinkle twinkle little star
all right ashley put it up ashley put it
up go on
i i this this [ __ ] will not
leave my record
yes yes
okay okay so
um so i guess i'll go through it from
right from left to right sorry i'm sure
you know all these i don't know the one
i don't know this one you don't know
that one that's that's the uh that's one
of the two japanese ones on the edge i
know three japanese ones so
uh top left is muse
yeah yeah yeah uh we've got we got music
we've got muse and then we have bradio
and then we have the kooks or is it no
it's just kooks right
um we have the killers we have michael
jackson mj we have mj come on uh we have
zutu mayo uh we have daft punk arctic
monkeys and obviously the uh fully
cooley sound i don't know why i thought
that was ben's still off for
all right all right so where where do
you want to start off uh who cooks i
like them that much okay so okay so the
reason i put the kooks there right all
cooks like is it the cooks or is it just
cooks
i'm obviously a bad fat is that cook is
it the cougars okay that's that's what i
thought and it was this is specifically
inside in the inside out the album
because it's one of the few albums i
actually have listened to all of the way
um and the reason i put the cougs in
there is because they are originally a
bland from brighton right
and you've got to represent that
homecoming no no no no exactly but like
i did not know this yeah i did not
notice for the longest time right but
listening to their music
and listening to this album especially
before i found out they were from
brighton i was just like [ __ ] this
literally epitomizes the brighton vibe
and like what it is like being a
teenager growing up in brighton right it
literally like epitomizes the vibe of
like going to like this random [ __ ]
beach party or just going to a random
house party in england sometimes that
privileged lifestyle
you know you know you know it's uh and
uh you know you know trying to pick up
chicks or just you know just
heavily binge drinking or whatever right
like if i had to pick a show for example
a tv show that epitomized british
teenage life it is the in-betweeners
right if you've seen the in-betweeners
i've not seen a more accurate
representation of what it is to be like
growing up
uh growing up at around like college age
which college age is kind of like high
school age right
and to me the kooks is
if you listen to this album it is
growing up in brighton college age so
about 16 to about 16 to 18 years old um
and that's why it's on there uh i feel
like i only know one song
i think there are like two big songs on
there there's like naive and like yeah
so nice
it's really like
really like drawn out yeah like every
every word i think and i think it's like
she moves in her own way that's the
other side oh i know that song yeah yeah
[Laughter]
that one that one is like burned into my
head it is because
all the time in the uk that was that was
the song that like introduced me to the
kooks but like i feel like those are
like the two most like naive and she
moves in her own way as like like the
two most poppy songs in their album
because definitely their later albums
they got like what they like way go away
like way on the poppy side of things
like they were kind of like kind of like
a maroon 5 in that sense like you know
you compare like early maroon 5 albums
uh to like the later maroon 5 albums and
it's just like okay this is like night
and day yeah this is not in there this
is like okay there was a point where i
like maroon five and then there's this
like billboard one hundred maroon five
you don't know does she moves like
jagger
yeah yeah yeah you don't like sugar
sugar they're great no no sugar but i
would stick up for like early maroon
five i i think aluminum five was
actually pretty damn good
um
but yeah i mean like i don't really know
what else to say about the kooks that's
that's why the kooks is on there if you
want to have a good band hey yeah it's
it's it's a good match it's a good indie
band okay so a lot of these
uh
a lot of these a lot of bands i wanted
to put on were of course indie bands
especially a lot of
indie bands from england i guess because
i did i did go through i think the the
period of life in my life where i went
where i listened to the most music is
probably in like between high school and
university where i listened to a lot of
[ __ ] indie bands
um and a lot of that was because i was
actually in a band myself i don't i
don't know if i were you yeah i don't
know if i've ever talked about this no
you've never tried we've never talked
about it have i never mentioned never
mind what did you even play yeah what
did you play i play guitar what
seriously i'm i'm serious did you stop
playing why i not started a band
do you know how
you've mentioned that you used to play
guitar like a little bit this feels like
something you should mention more yeah
this feels like a personality trait i
feel betrayed that you haven't mentioned
this yeah i mean um i guess like okay so
i i guess i gotta get to get into this
story then okay let's okay let's let's
let's let's start right at the beginning
next you're going to say that you're a
member of the cooks
so i i guess the reason i wanted to
learn how to play guitar in the first
place is my first choice on that it's
muse um i remember the first time
hearing plug-in baby and just hearing
that riff and like just gone like
something just clicked in my mind and i
was just like i need to be able to play
i need to be able to play this and like
i remember before like my um my mom had
always tried to get me to learn guitar
because she's just like you know people
play guitar oh cool you know my mom
thinks it's cool and i'm just like she
set me for like guitar lessons as a kid
and i never really took them seriously
right i was just like i'm doing this
because my mom wants me to do it right i
can play [ __ ] oasis wonder wall
whatever the [ __ ] you know
which i would argue is the only song you
need to know yeah the only song you need
to know okay i was just like whatever
and i only we only owned a acoustic
guitar at the time yeah and then i went
uh i remember i went into secondary
school which is like just
i guess just before high school age in
in the uk or is it high school age i
don't know secondary school yeah um and
i remember the first time hearing
plug-in baby and i was just like why did
they never teach us how to play this in
[ __ ] guitar lessons what the [ __ ] i i
i know how to play a bar code uh a bar
chord sorry yeah um i'd like like what
do i need to do to learn how to play
this and so the first thing i did was i
uh did your acoustic yeah i ditched my
acoustic i signed up for guitar lessons
uh in my in my secondary school and i
was like mother i would like an electric
guitar
did she get you one huh did she get you
one uh she i remember we we got like a
like a [ __ ] cheap ass electric guitar
basics no not even amazon basics i got
one lap that was like on like a car boot
sale or something like that
which was what
um so i can't even remember what my
first guitar was it was it was it was a
[ __ ] guitar it was it was one where i
had to like replace all of the [ __ ]
strings on the guitar because all of the
strings were like rusted already
didn't like at that point i didn't even
know how to like properly tune or uh or
like change the strings of a guitar so
like my teacher at the time had to uh
teach me how to do it but uh yeah i mean
um that's when i that's like that's when
i first look properly got into learning
how to play the guitar um and uh and
at that point as
the point where i was building up my
skill level to uh you know be able to
play plug-in baby which eventually i did
and uh and then i actually now that i
think about it once i learned how to
play plug-in baby i that my drive to
like improve my skill level just kind of
just stopped so i have reached peak
i'm like never a need to play you know
when i like you know when you've reached
the goal you set for yourself and i just
never found a next goal to set for
myself so like for me it was just like
play guitar to play plug-in baby i can
do it now mother i can stop playing the
guitar my god dispose on this
i always wanted to play guitar hero
play guitar
yeah so uh yeah and then and then so
then in that time uh one of my friends
he he wanted to start a band and i was
like you know what why not i've i've got
nothing better to do at this time you
know i'm uh i can play the guitar might
as well use it for some first day
lessons do you know plug-in
twinkle twinkle little star
yeah
um and so yeah i mean i joined because i
wasn't doing really doing anything with
the guitar aside from trying to learn
how to play plug plug in baby so i was
like maybe i'll just join the guitar
maybe i'll just join a band for fun yeah
um and i mean i don't think we were the
greatest band but
did you ever play yeah yeah we played
like a bunch of gigs actually i got like
what yeah yeah i've like i think the
biggest crowd we played in front of in
was
kind of like 500 to a thousand people
what what okay
oh my god how have you never told this
story okay so
okay so
i remember when we were trying to think
of the band name i i think we have like
a [ __ ] stupid bad name they're
they're always stupid
our band name we we like
we like try to like brainstorm a bunch
of [ __ ] band names and like nothing
just seemed to click because nothing
everything sounded either like too metal
or you know too campy or whatever
uh and then we just went on we just went
with the name nine and a half pounds
because
uh because the month before my mate uh
one of the lead singer went on a diet
and he lost nine and a half pounds and
that was like we were just like you know
what we don't know what we're gonna call
our band let's just use this as just the
name until we think of the actual name
of the band and then that just and then
that was just like that's amazing as
with a lot of names you know uh you you
just sticks right you pick a filler name
and you're just like can't be also
changing now
so you would just like play
any song what kind of songs did you play
um so i'm used that just means no i mean
uh we wrote our own songs um so we'd go
so my mate had uh we we uh we went to
the drummer's house because uh my
our always gather at the drama you
always gather the drama's house because
you can bring your [ __ ] guitar you
can bring your you know you can bring
your you can bring your bass or whatever
to someone's house you can't you can't
transport a drum kit yeah yeah you know
what i mean so um at first we went to
the drama's house to practice and then
and write songs and eventually we had
like this really like
this really like [ __ ] old music
studio that suck that a friend of a
friend of a friend yeah dad owned you
know you know that kind of you kind of
thing
and you walk in it's like a back alley
and like the [ __ ] door hinges like
like broken in like 10 million times or
something and you're like i might get
stabbed here but they have a drum kit
and a recording studio
so whatever that's just amazing and i
remember the biggest uh the biggest gig
we played
was like we signed up to what was the
equivalent of like a battle of the bands
kind of kind of kind of deal bro you had
an anime arc yeah so so okay so like
this is just this is just back
part of the reason why
i got so into back and why beck was one
of my like my favorite did you say this
when you were talking about ben yeah i
think i did mention it i must
okay
okay so we were just a band for fun we
weren't taking this seriously
um but like we we met like a lot of
bands who were like [ __ ] amazing that
came out of our school because like i i
guess part of the other reason why we
formed the band was because we are the
school i went to was a performing arts
school so a lot of people there were
doing
were doing performing arts whether it
was theater or music or something so
there were like some people in my school
like my classmates who were taking like
music really really seriously we were
just like whatever i'm learning guitar i
i'll just play i'll just play in the
band because whatever that seems like a
cool way to spend my time um and so
i remember for this battle of the bands
we literally had to like audition to get
into this battle of bands right and it
was like it was a pretty big deal at the
time because this gig was pretty famous
for like a lot of students and there was
like
there was sometimes there would even be
people from music labels who would
attend like events like this yeah
so we weren't like we weren't expecting
anything to come out of this we were
just like you know what they're holding
auditions at our school and we could
sign up so we're just like what we got
to lose we didn't really we we didn't
really expect anything because we didn't
really think that we were that good of
bands right uh so we obviously we
obviously auditioned um and it was
literally like the [ __ ] x factor kind
of thing kind of deal right because the
big golden bars are in the middle yeah
yeah because literally we'd uh because
because our school was a performing arts
so we had like a theater set up right
and the theater we had like a drum kit
in the middle and we had there were
judges on there oh wow and uh we had to
uh we had to play two songs right we had
to play two songs in front of the judges
and i remember god plays plug and baby
yeah and the crowd goes wild sorry and
now for our second song plugging baby
one more time the montage starts
everyone gets up on that okay
we were hearing some of our [ __ ] some
of the other bands that were playing
before us yeah and we were just like
[ __ ] my life we have to follow these
guys
we gotta follow these guys what the [ __ ]
and so and so i remember thinking we're
not going to get on because there were a
lot of other bands that were [ __ ]
better than us i'm going to say that
yeah but so we went on uh we just we
just played our songs you know the
the judges you know waved us off
whatever we didn't expect much and so
we didn't get into the battle of the
bands we actually became like a backup
choice just in case just in case you
know okay uh
and so we went on with our lives and
then we get a call like a week before
the event i went
and they were just like uh so one of the
one of the bands has dropped out and we
got an extra space in this battle of the
bands concerts um do you wanna do you
wanna come on and we're like what the
[ __ ] this this is literally carol on
tuesday like that's exactly what's
happening carol
it's an anime
and so we were just like
i mean yes but how the [ __ ] can we
prepare in a week yeah for this battle
of the bands which is which is like
other bands have prepared for for like a
good month or two you know like like
playing with a band is [ __ ] more much
more difficult than you imagined it if
you've never played in band before uh
because you're in a live setting right
and a lot of things can go wrong and you
need to be on the same wavelength as
your other band members
i've played plenty of gigs and some
games are better than others sometimes
you make mistakes and sometimes you know
you you're not in sync with the rest of
the band and you need you know you need
to be tight you need like the
performance needs to be tight
so you need a lot of practice so uh we
said yes but we didn't really
we didn't really have time to practice
the songs that we wanted to practice
right um but there was like well that
was like one joke song that we had
practiced uh we had practiced before
because we didn't really have any gigs
coming up and it was i just had sex with
a lonely hand no no it's it was an indie
rock version of hit me baby one more
time
by britney spears that's [ __ ] awesome
it was it was it was hit me baby one
more time by britney spears hell yeah
and and we were just like well we don't
really have time to practice some of our
more complicated songs so let's just put
that in the set whatever whatever right
um and i remember we had the
conversation before of um we always
wanted the experience of like having the
audience you know i having the audience
sing part of the song yeah like like
like a lot of bands ago yeah of course
and
uh and i remember we were having this
discussion of you know the perfect point
of this song would be uh what's what's
the line um
how does he be one more time go again uh
i think he's thinking about the chorus
right yeah yeah uh with me baby one more
time no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no i gotta
get it no no
[Music]
the line goes my loneliness it's killing
me yeah and uh yeah and we were saying
that would be an awesome point for like
the audience like chime in but like we
were just to do the end to do the
because that would be that that would be
like an awesome feeling yeah of course
but we were just like no we're not going
to do it because like
what's more embarrassing than like
stopping because then stopping a song
letting the audience sing
and no one sings like we did not have
the [ __ ] balls
right
um and so i remember
i remember we we we go to the battle of
the bands and it's like the biggest
audience so far normally we're used to
performing for like 50 to 100 people so
this was like a lot which is which is
still a lot you know we're just a lot
but like this was like about 500 people
it was that like
it was like concord 2 which uh if you
know in uh if if you know brighton congo
2 is actually one like one of the
biggest venues that's not like the
brighton that's like that's not the
bright and the main brighton venue is
like a lot of big indie bands go there
um
and so uh we go on stage and we're just
like guys we're not gonna take this
seriously a lot of these bands are
[ __ ] amazing we're just gonna have
fun we're just so anime we're just we're
just going to have fun right um and i
remember so we go on stage we play the
set and
this is this is me like playing on pure
adrenaline so we're so we're not
practiced at all we're not as tight as
we want to be in terms of our
performance but i
seeing like for some reason just like
playing in front of like the biggest
crowd kind of like hyped us up and i
can't really explain the feeling but it
just like something that day just
clicked you know you know you know some
days where you're just like in the zone
like that day for some reason all of us
were just in the zone we were like at
peak performance right yeah and then i i
remember we uh we decided because
because we were going to meme it up we
decided we were going to end it on hit
me uh on hit me baby one more time yeah
uh the rest of it was just going to be
our original songs and we're going to
end it on that because we're just like
we don't care whatever yeah the audience
is probably not going to like it because
it's [ __ ] britney spears but we're
just gonna have fun with it um and then
i remember when we start playing the
song
somehow the audience just like erupts
right
the audience because like this is not
the type of audience that would listen
to [ __ ] britney spears
they're here for like [ __ ] arctic
monkeys they're here for [ __ ] block
party or you know like the classes or
some [ __ ] like that and and i remember
playing this song right and obviously we
had agreed that we weren't going to stop
the music with the and i yeah right but
you saw we saw the energy in the crap
right you had no choice and and and we
were like it was it was such a it was
one of the most surreal moments in my
life right where we had this we had this
performance where we were just all like
in this
we were in flow you know we were just in
in like we were like kuroko basket in
the zone and i remember i remember the
the moment was coming up right
i looked over i looked like i went to
the drama that's so out of it
because i remember i was just i was like
i want to do this but we haven't we we
agreed that we wouldn't and i remember i
want i remember thinking i want to do
this and i remember looking at the
drummer and he had like the same look as
i did
i looked over the basis and the bases
were just like
oh my god
and then then
and he nodded at me and then uh and then
i i looked over to the singer and in the
corner
he sees me on the corner of my eye uh at
the corner of his eye and i'm just like
and then he nods back and i'm just like
okay it's going to happen and so and so
it goes my loneliness is killing me
silence
and i and like the [ __ ] entire like
concert hall just like [ __ ] they
complete the line and it's just like
i can't explain that [ __ ] feeling it
it is it's better than saying it is like
it is like the biggest orgasm i've had
in my life like
poor sydney
because because it was i don't know it
was it was kind of like a disney moment
for me because like somehow everything
just [ __ ] came together and then we
just we continued the song and it was
the best like the best reaction that
we've ever got from a crowd
um
so the battle of the bands was done by
votes and there were 10 bands there we
came in third oh [ __ ] did you get
anything any fries no we didn't get any
prizes we didn't get any prizes but that
that would get the biggest orgasm of his
life yeah that was that was the peak of
my of music career that was that was the
peak of my music career
it all went down i mean that's pretty
ridiculous considering this one how many
[ __ ] hundreds of bands that have
probably never experienced that true and
that from that day onward he uh
relinquished the name grant
and became gone
he wasn't right to use the name leveled
up and evolved yeah i can't use the name
anymore that's great how the [ __ ] have
you never brought this out i never
brought this up i don't i just i swear
i've said i've been in a band before and
no one's ever just
everyone's been in the band before not
everyone's been in a band before oh yeah
i've been in a band for like 10 seconds
until i realized it's a horrible idea
yeah i don't know i mean yeah that's why
i really liked back because i looked at
beck and i'm just like
i get that that's my life so you were
like actually good at guitar
i was like competent i guitar well you
played in front of people that's pretty
good yeah i mean i played in front of
people but
i mean that's right
my mind book that's pretty good so we're
starting a band called ten and a half
pounds soon
and a half
looking forward to a guy he's like
unlocked memories in me like i heard the
[ __ ] zelda
thing when you were like i i remember i
tried to learn guitar well i tried but i
think my parents nudged me towards it
right i just remember being in in
someone's house playing guitar trying to
do twinkle twinkle little star right and
i just was like i don't know
i said i don't get this and then he was
like gave me this device that was a
tuner but i don't know what it did uh
he's like you got to do it until it goes
green the light yeah i was like
why
it all sounds the same
it all sounds very similar
it's just one beep to one another and my
parents bought this tuna for me and i
remember just even at that time i was
like eight i was like
my parents just wasted their money on
this channel i'm never gonna get good at
this
so i've never never learned guitar and
then i remember i went to learn drums
which seems pretty fitting for me
because i'm you know you just need a
sense of rhythm yeah just like hand eye
coordination which is great i've had
great hand-eye coordination
unfortunately no rhythm
so
that that was the crux of that one and
that was over with and i never really
learned drums i went for like a year and
i never really learned anything really
they try to make they try to teach me
how to read the sheet music uh that's
what i was like no yeah i don't want to
do this like jazz drumming methods yeah
yeah i i think i i stopped learning at
the point where
she music started to become like a thing
of my lessons i'm just like i don't like
this anymore
this used to be fun when we were just
talking about beeps and boobs now you
brought reading into this yeah
that's why i draw the line yeah because
like i
like like like i think we said this last
time where i go by i go by feeling like
and that's what i went when i wrote like
a protagonist because i don't understand
a single thing about [ __ ] music
theory you know i know which chords
sound nice in my head and sometimes i
have like a nice like like beat or
rhythm in my head and i'm just like
let's try to play this out guitar i i do
not know what [ __ ] you're literally from
like like 100 like in the way
for some reason one of my friends was
like yeah we need a singer i was like uh
all right i'll do it then i'll do it
i'll do it yeah i i couldn't sing it all
right i didn't have any confidence in it
but the first song i'm not even kidding
the first song that we had to learn is
the only one i ever bothered learning
yeah we never did anything this this
died by this song guess what song we had
to sing
museum no it's [ __ ] smash mouth
i remember like actually why did you not
pursue it i didn't i have like very
vivid memories of me actually seriously
trying to learn how to sing yeah [ __ ]
all-star before it was a meme right
right and i when this came when this
became a huge meme i was like this is
like i had like nam flashbacks
like just like oh my god oh my god this
is the song
i i need to hear a an actual serious
cover of smash mouths
because every time we go to karaoke of
course all star comes up like at least
four or five times throughout the night
and every time it's just kind of singing
like a dumb voice i want i want you to
actually like
be serious and like try and if i
seriously try and sing yeah i feel
vulnerable
i feel open criticism i can't do it no
no no i won't if i'm the clown it's safe
no no no no no safety i get that corner
i get that i'm bad at something you
can't hide you can't hide now that
you've said that you hide behind my
clown makeup thank you very much now
that you've said that you have to do
that so that was your first pick
that was my first picture
oh my god it's been like four hours this
year um so i mean like news is one of
the only bands i've also seen live
they had such amazing hair look yeah
dude yeah brady's got the best leash
yeah michael michael jackson's running
for his money on his [ __ ] afro like
this this is like the early days of
brady as well brady like his afro like
like now is
huge so yeah i mean i've also seen brady
alive as well i mean like the reason i
put brady up there is because uh i
discovered bradio with sydney during
like a really tough and time trimed time
in like our lives when like i was living
in london working for the bbc i like
every every day was like every day was
like depressing as [ __ ] of course
you know especially with like the
compute that i had but for some reason
for some reason no matter how down my
day was i put on a bradio song and and i
am instantly happy like for just like
that five minutes or three minutes
whatever i could just feel glad and
happy for a second yes is it bad i can't
remember which songs they've done which
animations they did death parade over
there
[Applause]
it was not only that song but i remember
what really saw me on bradio was first
time i heard that song of course it was
a banger everyone heard the death parade
opening and they knew it was a banger
but it was actually their music video
right because if yeah if you see their
music video it's just like four dudes
having fun with the green screen and
it's just it's like got such this it's
got such a charm to it right because
they do they do this a lot with some of
their music videos where they're just
like taking the piss and like trying to
like
try trying to like either replicate this
anime opening because what they did in
this music video was they've tried to
replicate the anime opening of death
parades yeah just with a shitty green
screen
and it's and it was just like using like
you know very basic cosplay and a green
screen and makeup and all the stuff and
it's just it's got such a charm to them
because it just shows that it just feels
like it's for dudes having fun having a
[ __ ] blast and not really giving a
[ __ ] about what the world thinks about
them you know my other favorite music
video by them is a golden liar
it's just it's literally just like them
on stage yeah yeah and they're just
[ __ ] having the time of their life
yeah it's such a good song and it's such
a good music video it's so fun such such
a good bass line as well it's like the
funk in that bass line oh
so good that's so funny i want to listen
to them
yeah yeah you should i i feel i feel
like you'd like them honestly like the
rest of their like discography is like
nothing but bangers like i haven't heard
a bad radio song yeah uh before we move
on from muse though
like i'm i have like i have a funny
story or not a funny story because like
i remember when i saw them live uh it
was in thailand right and like i
there was a thai no that's that's the
thing right that's so so it was when i
was living in thailand right and it was
so [ __ ] random because i'd gone my
entire life being a massive muse fan
living in england you know and just
never getting the chance to [ __ ] see
them at all because they they never
performed uh when i was in england and
so like the first time in my life that i
actually got to see them perform was it
in bangkok thailand like what what the
[ __ ] right so i remember like i remember
thinking this is this is this real this
is so surreal that i'm going to be able
to see muse in thailand yeah out of all
the places in the world i could see muse
so i remember going to this concert
where i'm
dragging sydney along because because of
course even though she wasn't
as big of a muse fan as i was i needed
something to go with me yeah and so i
remember like
this was like the highlight of my month
because i'm like [ __ ] me man i get i get
to see muse i get to [ __ ] see muse
and i remember
i remember going to go to the concert
and i'm going to um
go to the stage and just like eagerly
excited for them to come on
and i remember the first band that came
on was a band called the ruse
the ruse okay okay so that's that's
r-u-s-e right right
so
i forgot that they needed a supporting
band yeah right i've thought like it's
so
my first thought was
have we just gone to the wrong [ __ ]
concert was was is this a muse concert
or is it
like like what is this like the thai
knockoff of the muse what's going on and
then they start playing and i'm like
okay maybe they're just gonna play one
song and then they play the second song
i'm like okay maybe maybe they're gonna
play two songs and then muse is gonna
come on they play five songs
and
after the fourth song i'm just like have
i made a terrible mistake and we've just
come and we just come to come to bangkok
thailand to see the ruse
did they end up coming home
but like
like i was just like i just remember
thinking uh i at first i was like you
know maybe it's a sporting band and then
like four songs later i really hope i
didn't just spend all this money to see
a [ __ ] knock off muse man man you're
dude by the way
did they do that on purpose they have
the rules supporting the muse maybe
possibly they must have they must have
chosen them on purpose right there's no
there's no [ __ ] way you could be a
supporting artist you change your name
yeah what's your name to the ruse
no reason why just do it yeah but don't
copy my homework too hard
i would be bricking it if i got there
they're like welcome the ruse and i
checked the ticket right now
i literally like because like i
literally when i literally had to go
outside just to check that uh the main
poster said muse
like i was coming in to see muse perform
i go outside and it's like yes it is
muse go back in still the ruse i was
like maybe they made a mistake out front
on the
maybe they got the letters wrong i don't
know
i mean
i've seen enough knock-off things in
southeast asia to be like maybe they
just pretended to be muse this entire
time the thai version yeah
that'd be so funny
um but yeah i saw them live and they
were absolutely absolutely so incredible
i i'm shocked you put the killers on
here do you like more than the one song
do you like more than mr bright side yes
yes i i like ruby ruby ruby that's
that's the chiefs
yeah
that's how little i know about the
killers yeah this sounds so simple
do they have any other songs yeah they
have mr bright sides uh apparently their
latest album is really good that one i
actually i had sheer i think
i actually haven't heard that lately
yeah
so why are they on the list huh why are
they on the list um because i think like
the killers was my university life right
my university yeah uh i was actually
like already into the killers before
like mr brightside came to like take
over the uk scene you were fans before
they were popular well kind of but like
they also really just exploded onto the
uk scene uh with somebody told me um
that was like that was like the first
song that really exploded like i was
already into indie rock at the time and
for the longest time i thought they were
a british rock man everyone does yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're like a mormon
americans though yeah yeah yeah yeah so
like for the longest time i thought that
they were a british rock band the same
way as like arctic monkeys were um and
you know and a lot of other british
indie bands yeah because they came out
in that time but uh yeah they i didn't
know they were from america but uh they
were like the one
indie band that i listened to still
throughout university because the reason
i stopped listening listening to a lot
of indie music is because my band broke
up because we all went to university
right um but i mean i listened to the
killers and
i don't know which album is which songs
but i know i listened to a lot of see
i'm i'm drawing a [ __ ] blank right
now yeah yeah um i just know i've
listened to a lot of killers uh and the
reason it's on here is not only because
i listened to them a lot
in university but it's also the first
band that uh me and sydney bonded over
oh oh so
so
okay so uh uh so sydney likes to quote a
lot of songs to like a lot of people
that she hung out with right and
apparently she told me that the only
time someone had completed a song lyric
that she had quoted instead of just
being like cindy what the [ __ ] you
talking about was uh when she quoted the
killers to me via text and she was she
just randomly said
oh
somebody told me
not somebody told me uh i got seoul and
i'd reply back
the absolute irony [ __ ] me i'm just like
this is this is i'm i'm drawing a
[ __ ] black right now
what's what's leaving my god
i'm not a soldier is that the line is
that this is like this is like me trying
to remember lyrics right because i'm
just like i'm just like i got soul i'm
not a soldier or something like that
this is okay okay like i said i don't
listen to lyrics like i just i just know
you managed to quote back that one yeah
that's that's the one line he managed to
call that yeah that's that's the one
line i managed to quote back and uh and
she was like well you're you're a killer
fan you're the one you're you are the
one you you are the first person took a
very big gamble replying with that you
got to look like a [ __ ] idiot yeah
they're like what's wrong with god he
said he's not a soldier or something
bizarre
yeah but uh yeah so the killers hold a
very you know a very very deep place in
my heart not not only because i listen
to the killers and i am reminded of
university life um but also because it's
part of the reason that i met and bonded
with my partner that i'm with now so and
i also saw them live in bangkok by hand
as well
it's so
yeah i mean i remember like the first i
remember seeing them live and the first
song that they played was mr bright side
and obviously mr bryce side you're gonna
start off strong is the song that
everyone everyone knows right um and i
remember it was such a surreal
experience just hearing a song that i'd
listened to so much in my childhood
right and i it was almost like it was it
was almost like a weird out of out of
[ __ ] body experience right where i i
had had this song that was that meant so
much to me when at one point in my life
and i saw them now
at the age of like 25 26 or something
like that like way later um and it's
just like a wave of just like it was so
surreal because at what it was like a
wave of like memories and nostalgia but
also like
me living in the moment like
it's it's so weird to describe because
just hearing them live and hearing like
it was like my life had like built up to
this one moment you know
i don't know because yeah because
because i'd never seen a band that i
loved so much as a kid
um later in life until that one moment
so it was just it was just such an
incredible moment for me i will never
forget hearing mr brightside for the
first time
um
and then we have uh michael jackson okay
so i mean i also like vanilla so
okay so the reason that michael jackson
is on there um is because
so as a kid
i went through a phase where i was you
spoke about this right yeah i think you
have really i feel like i've this is
weirdly familiar gone talking about on
the podcast yeah yeah so i don't know if
i have talked about it on the podcast
but as a kid i went through this massive
phase where i was obsessed with michael
jackson
like like i i was i was a weirdo
i don't know if i've said it in private
to you guys or on the podcast but like
yeah i went through a phase when i was
like just an obsessive michael jackson
kid like uh
i think everyone's gone through their
faces the target audience
[Music]
this was okay this is this was before
that phase but you know
regardless of what his image was you
know or what happens later in life
though you know his music [ __ ] slaps
of course it's like yes it's vanilla but
it's it's a classic formula i [ __ ]
love the song uh pretty young thing but
it's so hard it's so hard to listen to
that song
because the lyrical content you know
yeah you know how when like they're like
separate the art from the artist i do
but sometimes it's really [ __ ] hard
to yeah that that song definitely didn't
mean
that's one of those songs i'm like why
why this song is so good but why do they
have to be ruined i literally cannot
listen to that song without being like
this is great oh
no and then you remember what it was oh
oh
mj i feel like but like so many songs
are amazing yeah yeah mj's just one of
those like artists that i feel you could
be at any party or like any convention
like yeah with with any amount of people
that could have completely different
personalities on everything the moment a
michael jackson song comes on everyone
is unanimously like [ __ ] yet it's okay
it sounds amazing yeah i mean like i i
think we talked about this before but
like i don't think we'll ever see
someone that had the reach or was like
as famous as michael jackson was people
by standing there
yeah yeah because because like part of
the reason i got into michael jackson
was because my dad actually introduced
me to michael jackson i remember he
bought like a vhs of like the top 25
hits of i think it was like holy [ __ ]
anniversary i wish i had like a deep
story of every single pick i don't know
this is the reason i had the pigs
because i was like i don't know how to
talk about the music i'm just going to
talk about something like slumdog
millionaires yeah every single answer
has like a goddamn 10-part back like
flashback this is insane yeah so like so
like it's it's one of the weirdest
experiences where like you go to like
the countryside in [ __ ] [ __ ] bum
thailand or something like they they
don't that's like they've never
experienced internet there they barely
have electricity there you know you go
to the [ __ ] chinese side and like
even going in the middle of nowhere
somehow there will be this one farmer
who will have this like old beaten up
cassette tape of like michael jackson
the thrill yeah and then and like they
wouldn't they would not know a single
word of english right and they're like
oh you you grew up in england you know
michael jackson you know you know you
you might
beat it and i'm not just like
how has michael jackson
how does michael jackson have this reach
well he's the king of pop right yeah
yeah yeah so like it's like it's still
like thinking about it it still blows my
mind just how famous
one person is i think thriller even to
this day is the most sold album ever hmm
i think so yeah well i just feel like i
have any idea yeah which is like stupid
that sounds right it's like it's like
by stupid i mean like the difference
between thriller and everything else is
like stupid like true it's insane yeah
because like you know you could go to
the bum [ __ ] middle of nowhere in japan
yeah and there'll be some like decrepit
70 year old 80 year old lady you know
putting rice in the rice fields and
being like oh my goodness yeah
decrepit
which jerry will say will taste the same
anyway
yeah who just like knows michael jackson
it's like yeah it's just everyone knows
it's ridiculous yeah yeah yeah it's it's
like we're it's like we're to think how
someone one person got this famous to
like
so many cultures and so many countries
that obviously had nothing to do with
the us or just like even listen to that
kind of music in the first place and uh
and and i mean yeah i mean thriller is
like i know putting like thriller on
there is kind of like putting like you
know [ __ ] zelda or something as your
favorite video game of all time but i
mean
i mean it's it's one of it's one of the
most legendary albums and he's one of
the most legendary artists for a reason
yeah and uh absolutely yeah and i was a
weird michael jackson kid i actually uh
did you learn how to moonwalk huh did
you learn how to moonwalk i attempted to
learn how to move i think i think i
could moonwalk at one point i could move
at one point too yeah could you actually
yeah genuinely genuinely yeah did you
figure it out by yourself or no no i
watch youtube i think i watch youtube
videos okay okay because i remember
trying to figure it out as a kid right
trying to figure out how the moonwalk
works right because like frame by frame
on the video just like analyzing the
moonwalk yeah yeah because and as as as
like as like a five six-year-old kid or
whatever i was like i got this i get
this looks exactly like like michael
jackson yeah and it was only until like
years later when youtube existed and
youtube videos existed did i realize
that's this is not i this is not how you
do the moonwalk i was doing it i was
just walking backwards
literally i was just like walking
backwards the inside so i'm thinking i
look cool as [ __ ] no no
i tried to do like the you know the leg
like pop thing that he does oh yeah oh i
tried to do that i tried to do that i'm
almost dislocated
i was like ow
joey became a pensioner i was like oh is
that why he shouts out because it just
[ __ ] hurts all right
yeah and uh this japanese artist yeah so
okay
[ __ ] me
hold on just frothing over michael
jackson just slurping up so that you can
add that to the uh compilation of god
tries to drink like a human being
so i guess uh this this is with demaio
but uh this is more of like where i put
her in just because i feel like she's a
genre of music that i
have just recently gotten into yeah um
and as with everything in my life
somehow everything always comes back to
uh domestic girlfriends
as it always does right so how i so
i'm not sure what this genre of music is
because it's not really just j-pop it's
it's like it's more of like okay so how
i would describe it you know do you know
do you guys know what utis are yeah of
course yeah so yutaites are like i
believe uh singers or musicians who
mostly originated from niconuco starting
who started off doing a lot of like
hatsune miku songs and stuff like others
yeah stuff like that so
a lot of
a lot of these musicians who came from
the scene ended up just like
i guess graduating and just made you
know start started making their own
songs with their own original artists
um and there's this i i don't know what
the genre is but there's a lot of
artists in this genre that i got
introduced to by the domestic girlfriend
opening because if
domestic domestic girlfriend is a very
divisive show i know that really i know
that um the opening [ __ ] slaps yeah
the openings are amazing the opening is
[ __ ] amazing i don't know the opening
i i'm not gonna even be able to attempt
to say it's hard it's it's not it's not
like a catchy song it is just a banger
yeah i'll take your word
yeah yeah and uh so i that's how i
discovered that artist minami
um and you know spotify recommendations
usually recommendations so i i i got
really really into minami and her songs
from the domestic girlfriend opening and
that kind of introduced me to this world
of artists like zutamayo eve
um who else is [ __ ] uh yorishika i
think yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so how i
describe them is like they they are
anime music that don't have an anime
that they play
you know what i mean yeah yeah again
like i've listened to this i don't
didn't know their name yeah but like if
you go to my youtube you can see i've
listened this person a lot yeah but it's
just like that genre of like i'm making
the anime in my head yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so like like a lot of these
artists that i listen to now have now
been picked up for like anime openings
right yes so i remember like i got into
i got into zutamaya and then i got into
eve um and then i remember listening to
the jiu-jitsu case load jutsu kaisen
opening when that came out and i for the
first time in my life i'm just like oh
my god i know this band
cause i've never heard this song before
but like they have such a distinct style
that i haven't i've had
that i had that moment where i'm just
like i've been following them since they
weren't underground
yeah it is the equivalent of the i've
read this when the manga wasn't big
right because you know because there are
so many artists in this field that have
now been picked up for an anime opening
or ending and and like there is this
there's this feeling of like yes you
have music slaps i'm [ __ ] proud of
you i'm validated for being a fan
and then i was like that would
[Music]
also i'm a little sad because now
everyone knows eve oh it's the jiu-jitsu
there's so much more than that listen to
the rest of their [ __ ] songs
um so yeah i mean like this is i guess
that's the kind of music i listen to the
most now that's like that's like my weeb
kind of it's really big in japan right
now especially
they're like yeah yeah
they're fun
i'm supposed to be at that phone i don't
know you're a big deaf punk fan i uh um
i was a big dolph park fan um during
like the discovery album actually and
like i'm thinking i'm thinking back and
a lot of my favorite songs or a lot of
my favorite music
have visuals to accompany them like do
you guys do you guys okay when you guys
listen to a song do you guys like do you
guys imagine like a music video in your
head or anything like that sometimes
yeah depends on the song for me yeah
yeah okay like what i'm doing yeah like
for me like if if i can't i can't
connect to a song unless i can imagine
some kind of story or some kind of
visuals to accompany that song and i
feel like i have such a random song i
have such a random music taste because
to to me like i don't really listen to
lyrics but if a song
emotes an emotion or a visual image in
my head then that's when i get really
emotionally connected to a song right
and to me that how i discovered daft
punk was i discovered it through
interstellar five five five five right
which was a [ __ ] amazing movie and
it's also one of it's also one of the
few albums i have listened to all the
way through based purely
from that movie right and from then on
from watching that movie and seeing the
story that they crafted from that movie
every daft punk song i listen to i have
such cool visuals
that that's why i became like such a
massive darth punk fan how did that even
happen that anime
was it literally just the guy i listened
to it was like holy [ __ ] i gotta make it
i gotta make an anime to go with this i
think yeah i don't know exactly but i
think matsumoto deji was like a fan of
daft punk and then they just like worked
something out and then because it's it's
so good i guess
i would like to know like uh what kind
of
what kind of like [ __ ]
what do i have to do to get multiple
deji to make a music yeah how did that
connection happen
because this was before anime was even
close to big you know this is this was
like underground as [ __ ] so yeah do you
have a do you have a favorite song from
the album
mine always changes quite often france
it's still hard uh from death punk it's
probably harder better faster stronger
that's good um yeah that's good i mean
for me for me it's like i know it's the
vanilla pig but like one more time will
always be one more time one more time
one more time with digital law
digital love is [ __ ] incredible
yeah
um and like i think the reason i picked
harder better faster stronger is because
i remember when i first started getting
to amvs and everyone everyone tried to
make linkin park amvs i did nothing but
just make da funk and b's that was that
was me man that was like every they're
already made
the rest of youtube went through the
rest of [ __ ] youtube went through a
linkin park phase i was here just like
it was like the entire discovery channel
in anime form aside from like not even
the movie but just like in naruto clips
and then when you heard the the kanye
west remix yeah you're just like oh my
god
i think that's i heard that before i
heard the
original death punk i discovered kanye
through that song huh i was like why who
was that that's like who's this guy
rapping over a dark punk song and then
that's so good
like at first i hated that song because
i'm just like why would you ruin harder
better faster stretch and then like the
more i listen to it the more i'm like
all right let's [ __ ] this [ __ ] slouch
yeah this is [ __ ] slap kanye all
right
you're you're a crazy [ __ ] but
he's gonna get big
i can feel it
this guy's gonna do stuff yeah i think
he's gonna be quite normal and arctic
monkeys obviously british obviously i
mean i again i mean i've already talked
about my indie phase i've kind of just
it wasn't just arctic monkeys it was
like everyone born around
are
generation-ish
loves arctic monkeys because if i would
have to say if i would have to say what
my
what influences i took when
uh when i was in my band right it was
bands like arctic monkeys
uh the klaxons strokes uh who else was
like big at the time razor lights
um also like red hot chili peppers and
foo fighters as well just like just like
any any in australia around that time
white stripes was massive oh white
stripes as well
i
so yeah i mean that that that slot is
just there for just for just mid 2000s
british check um your pillows and then i
have the pillows well i i put the
pillows there because i did go through a
phase where there was a lot of anime
music
on my playlist we've all been there yeah
we've all been there and i i feel like i
was the anime man at one point yeah yeah
yeah and good old times i knew it was
but like back then i didn't like i
didn't look up the bands behind the
anime music it was it was just anime
music you know what i mean and my apple
thing was tv size bracket
a lot of one minute 30 songs yeah and i
remember fuli kuli was like the first
entire ost that i've thought i took i
took this entire ost because every song
in the fuli kudu ost because it was
basically just the pillows album right
yeah it was just an album of the pillows
it was the first time where i took an
entire anime ast and put it on my mp3
player which wasn't even an ipod uh it
was like this like an actual like mp3
yeah yeah this it was it was like a
knockoff cheap ass like chinese mp3
player that i can't even remember the
brand uh because it doesn't exist yeah
probably doesn't exist anymore uh
because i couldn't afford a proper ipod
or proper like branded mp3 player i had
one that was like kind of like shaped
like a like a long pill it was like a
blue pill yeah and then you can put like
an aux cord and it was like a tiny tiny
screen and the name of the song would
like scroll across yeah oh
good times yeah kids will never
understand
and and and i mean like the pillow is
kind of it is again kind of just like
japanese but also has headlights i was
this close to putting the pillows on
mine but it didn't yeah
and and like i again like the reason i
really loved uh that soundtrack is
because flcl is kind of just like an amv
but yeah just just just in just in six
episodes
season good
it's good but nowhere near us it's not
as good as i've never watched it has it
has its moments you gotta watch the
first one what's it like to me like
ninety percent of why i love hoodie hulu
so much was because of the pillows oh
yeah um and the visuals were kind of it
was kind of like watching interstellar
five five five five again wow so if you
like the music you'll like the anime oh
yeah what if you're not into the music
and you're like
it's gonna be hard to not be into the
music yeah i mean it kind of it kind of
sets the tone of the entire show that
makes sense there's a reason why it's
like one of the most like famous anime
yeah people never shut up about fully
cool yeah why it's so amazing yeah yeah
but like it's it's it's like it's it's
like moments like this where
i was afraid whenever people were just
like yo well let's
pass the york's core let's see what your
music taste is and i'm just like [ __ ]
man what how am i going to explain yeah
like tv size narrator opening [ __ ]
like what is that what is that yeah but
at least it was like you know like hard
you know custom dry like j-rock right
like i was listening to like lucky star
opening before i was like that's even
harder to explain it's like yeah past
the yorks i'm like i don't think you
want the orcs man like
i definitely listened to too much hannah
montana at one point really more than
what more than i'd care to admit you
know i had in my test are both
obsessed with hannah montana
sounds good when i was like 13 i was
like obsessed with hannah montana i
don't know why so much so that one of
the first books i ever read was miley
cyrus's autobiography are you serious
i'm not kidding
i'm not kidding i wish that was a joke i
wish that was those strings
for some reason i was obsessed with the
disney channel when i was like 12 or 13.
that makes sense i think i was sold on
the dream that you can do whatever you
wanted to do yeah yeah i realized that
no it's not how it works
and you still have miley turned out
right uh yeah
and also i like the music for some
reason i think it's weird it's weird how
when you're 12 and 13 you're just
[ __ ] idiot i was i was more obsessed
with hillary doff
yeah like more than i don't know isn't
it weird how you have those phases yeah
miley didn't really click for me hillary
i was like yeah
i can get behind this
[Music]
i don't know why
i feel like everyone has that one thing
that they've they've like they've shoved
down and they're subconsciously
repressed and they're like i never like
this if you say if you say i did i did
not it's so inexplainable now that i
think about i was like why why i don't
like hillary doc i cannot explain to you
why was she like hot to me i don't know
i think i like the escapism that it
offered yeah yeah that could be a team
something
12 year old what's wrong with me and i'm
this jaded british man who likes beans
on toast but back then i had dreams and
stuff
there's a channel yeah what the [ __ ]
happened to you
anyway anime does that no he does that
[ __ ]
destroys dreams yeah i mean so that is
that is my three by three i don't know
if that's like random as [ __ ] um it
makes sense i mean like i
i feel like i've talked more behind the
stories of the stories of uh i just want
to hear more about you being in a band
now like how am i supposed to live
stories about living in the band
oh my god who's going to be next oh my
god it's it's the joey no one end of
episode
upside down sorry hill let's put jerry's
on this episode is sponsored by magic
spoon guys do you remember waking up as
a kid watching saturday morning cartoons
and eating that nice bowl of cereal i do
joey don't you miss that feeling god i
miss it so much like he can't really do
it as an adult anymore right well magic
spoon is the cereal for you adults out
there who want some of that nostalgia
back thank you i can actually start
eating this now i've been waiting to eat
did you know that inside of the magic
spoon cereal there's zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving and
each serving is only 140 calories isn't
that amazing did you also know that
they're keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free and low carb honestly no
joking me and sydney have been obsessed
with these which is why i was hungry so
i actually couldn't wait to start eating
these because like i these are actually
really good well if the boys haven't
convinced you i don't know what will so
if you want to get your very own medic
spoon click that link below to grab a
variety pack and try today and be sure
to use the promo code trash taste at the
checkout to get five dollars off any
order or go to magicspoon.com trash
taste and the magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked so again click
that link in description down below and
use coupon code trashtaste for five
dollars off or go to magicspoon.com
trashtaste to save five dollars today
back to the episode it's a pretentious
music critic time let's go
hold up can i guess these please guess
them this is okay i know this one
this is from that that one video is like
this is your rapper's favorite rapper
doctor doom
it's mf dude that's doctor
yeah he got his dog i know that
unfortunately he passed away not too
long ago as well right yeah yeah he died
of covert actually i recognize radiohead
yep that's that's radiohead yeah oh is
that who they are yeah
look i feel like i've seen him on tv
tomy york being on a tv show i don't
know
can we
google that am i going crazy maybe i
don't know
please
i'll be surprised if you can get anyone
else drake i know one of them
is this drake bell
yeah i know one of them's tall yeah
that's tall yes yeah
why do they all look the same
is this
a british men yes
it could be like the who or the sex
pistols or it could be one of them it's
not who or sex crystals but it's that
era yeah i feel like they all look good
okay i'm british they all look exactly
the same
okay so from left to right tall led
zeppelin okay radio ahead patreon
pink floyd nick drake mf doom american
football and maida jun
my brother's gonna [ __ ] kill me he's
absolutely obsessed with like led
zeppelin really yeah he's obsessed with
that he loves all of those that are band
oh yeah i mean i could have put like
nine just 70s hard rock bands as well if
i wanted to because i i love a lot of
their music but a lot at the same time i
have no idea what any of the bands look
like
like like you know that's what they look
like they all look like long hair like
black sabbath i know what ozzy osbourne
looks like now yeah i don't know what he
looked like
he got he looked so different back there
yeah ozzy osbourne actually looked like
a human yeah
oh oh it's eight year old japanese or
another that is getting dragged too fast
aussie is uh aged strangely
yeah when i saw him live it was uh it
was weird aussie is like you know those
those time lapses of like this chicken
nugget has been in the closet for 70
years and hasn't aged but it has and
it's that's how i feel i don't know why
is that a fair comparison
that's how i feel it's like it shouldn't
be alive but it looks boringly well yeah
it's like aussie now kind of looks like
if someone took ozzy osbourne deflated
him and then re-inflated him again like
what he's done like it looks like
someone took he was born and just like
he left him in water for too long
he had like hasn't he done like an
amount of drugs or inaudible oh yeah
yeah i mean i mean most he should have
died ages ago normally but uh he's some
i mean that's why he can barely talk now
like when i went to go see black sabbath
live it was like the the like you know
the the original line surprise is still
performing yeah i mean this was like
maybe five six years ago and it was
labeled their last tour right so i was
like oh of course i have to go that's
impressive that he's still able to
perform yeah that's the thing it's like
he came like from like when they all
came onto stage and like the music
starts playing and you just see this guy
just like hobbling across the stage
right and i'm like oh that's him there
he is and he just goes up to the mic and
he's like
normal for birmingham what are you
talking about and i was like
i don't know what you said man but
you you're sounding good and he's like
oh i'm good
oh i don't think you don't know it
generally that and he just starts
singing normally i was like why can you
not
why can you sing this is completely
you haven't lived in the uk test i can
understand him like perfectly
i'm not i'm not even joking
i could understand what he was saying i
don't know what it is man yeah the uk is
weird it doesn't matter it gives you
like uh like it's it's like the hard
mode of english
like once once you're trained in it then
you could he you could like distinguish
any access no difficulties understanding
english access yeah yeah i just grew up
around really strange ones but i guess
like black sabbath like so led zeppelin
for me is like kind of just
all of like the british like 70s like
hard rock man black sabbath can fit in
there like deep purple can fit in there
because like that's just like the music
my dad just grew up with and he was like
here do you know rolling stones and i
was like and i was two years old and i
was like what is the music and then he
just played rolling stones and i was
like okay i can get behind this and then
i think the first band i like really
connected to was led zeppelin yeah um
yeah like i [ __ ]
love it
okay
uh
immigrant song immigrant song um
[Music]
living in japan you'll meet like let's
say you're just me talking to japanese
people or whatever and they'll be like
oh i love i love british music
okay i'm thinking like [ __ ] watch which
are they gonna talk to because i don't
know any of them yeah it's always like
black sabbath let's settle in and
they'll be like the last thing what's
your favorite song i'll be like
[Applause]
this is where i feel like this is where
like my [ __ ] levels come to like how
well can i do this yeah yeah this is
really but basically uh like jimmy page
who's the guitarist for led zeppelin
he's the one who basically influenced me
to start guitar right yeah so like i
watched one concert from led zeppelin
and i was like that is the coolest
[ __ ] human alive like just like him
just shredding on guitars like i want
what he has i want that can i do that is
it a coincidence they're all posing very
similarly and
like they just happen to all have the
same looking posts i just yeah i mean
that's just like
we are a bear yeah we are a band we're
doing pretty well yeah we are a band um
he's no i think he's behind him he's
behind a door
he's not holding your door
he's just like holding it i'm taking
this home i'm taking it
um yeah so i guess like yeah so led
zeppelin's just like
like just my love for like 70s rock so
like black sabbath deep purple rolling
stones it's like really hard for you to
decide it's really hard cause you're
your music knowledge is vast yeah yeah
yeah and i feel like you have an
appreciation for music yeah way beyond
anything me and can't have yeah like me
and conus like a music puddle yeah yours
is like a music ocean you know
basically um and then i guess like kind
of in the same vein but i had to like
put it sim uh differently as pink floyd
in the middle
yeah yeah like i think i went to a
concert of pink floyd's well technically
just roger waters um and he and he
performed that pink flight has this
album called the wall yeah which is like
considered like one of the greatest like
concept albums joey has explained the
wall to me in great detail yeah i like
how you said they made this album called
the wall but like it's not like one of
the most favorite i don't know because
like because people always think like oh
yeah they made dark side of the moon
it's like that's the one i knew oh is
that the one that nostalgia critic made
right right yeah my favorite
critic i love that i love that amazing
amazing i love nostalgia critic but um
so he so roger waters was the guy who
like mostly wrote the wall but like the
entire band like did it as well but like
he went on like a tour all around the
world to perform the wall
um and so i got tickets to it like
miraculously from a friend of mine and i
was like oh my god my dream's gonna
[ __ ] come true like i get to see one
of my favorite bands but like it wasn't
a concert it was a [ __ ] stage show
right so like
again the whole concept of the wall is
like guy creates a wall that's like not
physical and then he like breaks it down
like get over his musical uh and uh
emotional barriers right super over
simplifying the element okay thank you
that's what i mean speed run but what's
amazing what was amazing about that
concert is that as they are playing the
songs throughout the album they're
literally physically building a wall on
stage oh that's cool with like it like
not obviously not made out of bricks
like like like big like styrofoam so
like after every song
the band members actually like go off
the stage and like place bricks on the
wall that's cool and then in the in the
second half and then in the first half
of the album he finishes building the
wall and then it just goes into like uh
an interest funded by donald trump yeah
definitely he was like i want it taller
and then and then the second half
the wall is built right but they build
it in front of the band so as the
concert is going on you can see less and
less
that's so cool and then the second half
of the album starts the entire
stage spins around
that's how we're looking and so now
you're looking from inside the wall
and then because that's the theme of the
second half of the album and then at one
point and at the end you spin the stage
round it was it was all just on this
like giant like lazy susan-esque like
just rotating thing right um and then
like second the second to last song on
the album the main protagonist of the
album he breaks down the wall and they
literally like blow this [ __ ] up
and just the pieces just go flying into
the crowd
and then the album just stands and like
i've never like
cried during a concert but that was the
first time i was like
like it was one of those concerts where
it's like you know normally like say if
you go see muse or like pendulum right
yeah you're [ __ ] like standing up
you're like grooving you're singing
along you're like [ __ ] yeah you know
like that kind of thing that was the
first ever concert i went to where i was
just like
my ass firmly planted on the seat and
just staring right and just like
listening and like taking it in because
it's like i wish i could have that
because i was shocked it was crazy it
was like one of the like i've been a lot
of concerts in my life but that was like
one of the most like
like ethereal is like the only way i can
describe it it's just so like oh my god
as someone who doesn't understand a lot
of like the deeper appeal of music like
what it what makes the wall such an
amazing album because like to me the
wall is just like the album you say if
you want to impress a dad
you know like like
you me you me you meet your girlfriend's
dad or something or you're like crazy do
you like it
i love pink floyd's the wall and yeah
like
easy [ __ ] brownie points yeah of
course of course i love ipas i love that
um i guess so i did like a whole
dissertation on the wall i did like a
fork so i took like music as like a
major right in high school because i
wanted to like pursue it at uni
obviously i didn't end up pursuing
anything your dads were like no no
you're asian jerry yeah yeah
you gotta do it you're gonna do it right
now
and uh like one of like i i did i
studied like musicology which is just
like music analysis basically yeah and
they were like and like the year-long
dissertation was
take an album and just like write a
dissertation about like write an album
like write an album review basically i
wrote like this like 40 page like
dissertation on the wall and like what's
like the most insane thing about the
wall is like not just the fact that like
the story is cohesive and like
all the songs flow together like there
is no pauses between any of the songs as
it flows from one song to another like
the entire album is connected to just
one big song but the most amazing like
mind-blowing thing is the fact that the
album literally repeats and that's cool
right right so the end the ending of the
last song fades into the beginning of
the first song that's really cool and
like that just like completely like and
and that's not just like a stylistic
thing like they did that on purpose to
show that like what this main character
is
is a never-ending cycle right right
right and it's just no it's just
constantly repeating over and over again
did that as well with uh
with the eagle right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so like uh the wall was i i'd
say it was like the first album to like
incorporate that style and like a lot of
obviously like tyler and like a lot of
artists took that yeah um but yeah i
mean like you know i've always said that
like you can make like a concept heavy
album right and like try and tell a
story but if the music sucks then the
music's gonna stop yeah
no one likes this song
you could have the most like deep ass
like message about like you know
whatever the [ __ ] you're trying to sing
about but if the song doesn't stick with
you then it's like there's no point yeah
the wall though is like every song's a
[ __ ] banger so even if you listen to
it individually it's like oh it's a
great [ __ ] song it still [ __ ]
slaps and then on top of that it's like
oh it's deep as well and profound and
it's lyrics it's like
what more could you ask for all right
um
you know and like what the one thing
though that annoys the [ __ ] out of me is
the fact that another brick in the wall
is from this album and it's like pink
floyd's most well-known song yeah right
just because and like it's a bob but so
many people just listen to it out of
context so they don't know what it means
because they don't know what it means
because like if you're actually in the
yeah because in the context of the album
it's a really [ __ ] depressing song
yeah
but it's just like played in an upbeat
and it's like it's like a great song
right like i'm not gonna fault them for
that but um yeah i don't know and like
all their albums just like that they've
never had a bad album it might be um so
there's that i know you love radiohead
and awful i love radiohead uh as as does
god yeah i do as well
spawned over radio yeah yeah i mean i'm
like i had to like pick between muse and
radiohead and i was just like uh muse
cut [ __ ] just slightly edges it out
because there's any radiohead songs i've
heard that have been like i love this
song
do you have you listen to creep
i don't like creep though the best song
but you guys always sing it
well i mean
this is like this it's it's like the
song because it's the least depressing
radio song yeah i don't really like the
depressing song yeah that's the weekend
scene
because at least it's gonna not be wrong
zombie yeah that's cause i started
listening to the lyrics i'm not gonna do
that again yeah yeah
um i don't know like i think for me
really hit what i appreciate the most
about radiohead is that they started off
as just like another 90s like
alternative rock band and then one day
they were just like
no i don't think i will i don't think
i'll be another 90s alternative rock
band i'm gonna try something else and
then okay computer came out and it was
like one of the most like
[ __ ] like revolutionary 90s like rock
bands ever and then like bands like muse
listen to that was like we can do that
too yeah yeah exactly
like coldplay as well was like heavily
influenced by radiohead and like all
these like big
alternative rock bands that went a
little experimental yeah i mean i mean i
feel like radiohead all the og in that
sense and yeah you know they they are
[ __ ] incredible and
the only reason i put muse above them
was because like i think i discovered
them both at around the same time yeah
yeah and i like but like there are so
many nights where i just like conk out
just listen to radiohead yeah and i
don't know it's to me if if i'm like
having an existential crisis i put on
radiohead man because there's nothing
that just like encapsulates that mood
more than just like a radiohead song
like sometimes i'm just like you know
what i just want to stay home and just
like
feel depressed
i wish i could feel this strongly about
music i did i remember i was at a place
that was like classical music being
played
and uh there was this guy
uh i was i was enjoying it i thought it
was amazing these guys are so talented
yeah and there's a guy who's uh in the
front and uh i could see him because it
was kind of like you know like a circle
in my semicircle you could see him and
he was like tearing up how good this was
yeah yeah i remember thinking like [ __ ]
how did he do that what do you mean
how'd he do that how does this mean so
much to him or how did it make him feel
this way because i don't understand i
like the sound a lot and i really
appreciated the artistry and everything
and i'm just like [ __ ] man i wish i was
just able to get what that guy had
what do you mean like emotional about
from the from the music it like really
made him emotional i can i can easily
yeah i can't get that i think there's
only i think there's only two [ __ ] up
i think there's only two artists in my
three by three that haven't made me cry
yeah yeah i don't know is that weird
that i can't i don't think i don't think
it's weird i wish i could get that like
so to me to me i have a different
problem because like i said i never know
like the deeper meaning behind the music
but like i've i've cried to so many
songs i have no idea what they're about
because they just make me feel things
i'm jealous i wanna feel these things
like i don't listen i don't know what
the lyrics mean i'm just like damn man
this i think like have you ever just
like sat down and just listened to music
yeah
and like but but i guess but i guess
you're listening to like darth bank and
[ __ ] yeah
it's not like digital love isn't
necessarily going to make you cry no
yeah you're right i don't know right i
guess just maybe the music i listen to
the way i consume it yeah maybe i don't
know but i don't think it's weird i
think there's a lot of people because i
i don't struggle to
i you know when i watch tv or anything
it's like super easy cry all the time
but there are people who like struggle
to cry watching movies that's right so i
guess it's the same thing so it's not
like i'm sitting there like
come on tears
i'm not there doing that it's just like
i don't i don't get what this guy's
getting i don't understand why i you
know maybe it's maybe maybe maybe as i'm
sure i might yeah i mean like to me like
music is
it's going to sound so philosophical now
it's kind of like a language you know
they're like they're absolutely like i
don't speak it it is like
i feel like there is something being
communicated through the language of
music and like i don't even understand
the words behind the music but i feel
you know there are times when i think i
feel the language behind it and like the
emotion that is being portrayed with the
music
that's true i mean if animals are
anything to go by you know dancing is a
language singing is a language somehow
they don't understand i imagine what
they're saying but it does something and
that's how they decided they yeah it's
just like pulls out like just some kind
of like primal yeah i think so i think
we have an inclination to feeling
towards it
i [ __ ] up like i don't know what makes
like i don't know what makes good music
like i i i don't know what makes good
music like literally i think what makes
good music is just if it makes you feel
a certain way i watch like musical memes
like
memes that only people who like or are
really into music would get yeah i'm
like i feel like this is funny i just
didn't i just couldn't understand why it
was funny right but like when somebody
plays like c minor or something like
that and i'd be like what
but yeah that was kind of funny that's a
bit of a deep cut but yeah i don't know
something along those lines um and then
i guess like tulle is like
probably the one band that made me love
metal again right um because like do you
want to run any of the songs
the name sounds extremely familiar i
mean they're yeah because joey's talked
about because
that's probably why i talk about them
all the time but like i think like i
think what like speaking of like primal
instinct i think like tall does the best
job of like pulling out like that primal
instinct in people when they look oh i
thought you were talking about bamboo
monkey
that was like primal instinct i love
that
there's a man called primal scream which
is good but not probably um yeah i don't
know like tall is like i don't think
they necessarily have like a hit
song or anything they're kind of like
one of those just like cult bands i
guess maybe like the pot
yeah sober the pot prison sex there's a
lot of like good songs but like i think
what makes it's like i think what makes
tool amazing and what i fell in love
with tall is that like
especially like this is a band that like
you need to listen to the lyrics okay
because it's like
like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
what i love about tall is that their
music just in general is so [ __ ] good
that you'll still enjoy yourself without
listening to the lyrics at all okay so
like um manny james keenan who's this
guy in the middle he's the lead singer
um in his in like tall stage shows and
like concerts normally the lead singer
is in the front right but maynard for
some reason is behind a curtain in the
back
like you can't even see him half the
time in concerts and that's because he
treats his voice as just another
instrument and if you want to listen in
closely on what he's saying then you can
if you don't want to you don't have to
there's the rest of the band to listen
to and i think that's like so [ __ ]
cool because it's like
again it goes back to that whole thing
of like you might have like some deep
ass message behind your music but if
your music sucks then no one's gonna
[ __ ] listen to it right true and like
tulla's like we can make banger songs
and we can make profound lyrics that
makes sense and it's like that's and
like i don't know it's just like
musicians it's like i i inspire to be
that um and yeah like i don't know like
like tool is one of those metal bands
that like even non-metal fans love
like i think every person i've shown
tall
who is like not necessarily into metal
music is like yeah this [ __ ] slaps so
like i would recommend if you don't like
metal listen at all
um and then oh god i guess we'll go to
doctor doom
mf2 i knew that i knew that um so mf
doom yeah uh
as as connor said is your favorite
rapper's favorite rapper i've seen that
youtube video yeah
i've
he's like a legend i i've heard so much
about this person but i've never
listened to their music yeah yeah so
basically like uh
tyler the creator and like you know
[ __ ] literally every like rapper
everyone loves and has gotten big has
been somehow inspired by mf2 just
because he's like i know he's like the
hip-hop fans hip-hop
if that makes sense
like because like i i feel like before
mf doom the only like hip-hop i ever
really listened to growing up was like
eminem but that's because eminem back
then was like [ __ ] inescapable like
yeah during like eminem show era eminem
like
yeah eminem was everywhere right like um
so like i feel back then i didn't really
like take hip hop seriously or like
rapping seriously other than eminem um
but then i listened to mf doom and i was
like okay hold on this might actually
this might this might actually be good
this might be some good music
um
again another artist you need to like
listen to the lyrics uh so yeah i
remember that i don't know who broke it
down was it vox or something vox did a
video
they did like an e1 video and i was like
this is amazing i just don't
i don't know yeah yeah i just i don't
know i i don't think i could ever garner
this by myself yeah yeah if you come
close to garnering this by myself it's
like when they tell you like why the
piano is a this specific piano is
amazing i'm like i'm sure it is it
certainly looks the part but i don't
yeah i don't know yeah no it makes sense
it makes sense i mean it's just like
good music in general um again i'm
having a hard time explaining why this
is good to people who
aren't on the same way any any hardcore
music fans here can appreciate your your
taste yeah okay well yes if uh if we
were more hardcore into music how would
you explain it then i i cause i am
curious um okay so break it down for me
focusing on 100 break it down okay so
tool for example um is like
like just this this sound and like this
singing style and the way they structure
songs is like it just has like a flow to
it like
one song could have like
seven or eight different parts that
sound like seven or eight different
songs but somehow they can stitch that
[ __ ] up together and make it sound so
cohesive and like together to the point
where like you could listen through a
15-minute tall song and it'll sound like
two minutes yeah i was gonna ask how
long is a typical tool song
they're not actually two like i mean
they obviously have like long songs as
well but i think like average tall songs
maybe like five six minutes it's quite
long which i guess it's long but i mean
like if you compare it to like say i
don't know a tangerine dream song like
like it's like a standard tangerine
dream song is like 20 minutes that's a
good name yeah sorry i've never heard of
them but that's a good name so tangerine
dream is this german group uh yeah
yeah
it's a great [ __ ] band name uh so
they're a german group uh that like does
like electronica and like ambient music
right and uh i put them there because
this is the one group i used to listen
to all the time in school while i was
studying how did you find out about this
band oh my god my dad showed me oh okay
i reckon everyone except maybe the
bottom three here i found that through
my dad all right um so like he yeah he's
raised you well man yeah
he's proud of you
um so tangerine dream ever been around
they're still around actually they've
been around for like 60 years almost
[ __ ] yeah i think they've been around
since like the early 60s in the stores
yeah 1968 yeah [ __ ] hell and they're
still they're still going um they have
like i think they have like 400 studio
albums or something
they have a big big big catalog like
it's stupid amount of albums they've
made um but like basically they like
really revolutionize like
chill electronica like meditation music
ambient music that kind of stuff so it's
like perfect study material like because
it's like there's no lyrics better than
lo-fi better than lo-fi should be that
low-fi hip-hop girl yeah look
hip-hop girl wishes they were tangible
um but yeah uh i don't know it's just
like really good like tangerine dream i
would say is like perfect background
music of just like if you're like you
know and like if you have like friends
over and you're just like you just want
to like hang out or you're like you know
you have your [ __ ] like
i don't know fiance's parents over right
and you don't want to sound you don't
want to look weird by like putting on
like tall in the background you know
tangerine dream is like the music to go
right because it's just like it's just
relaxing it's inoffensive it's just i'll
check it out yeah and like they got like
a lot of good stuff they did a lot of
like uh movie soundtracks oh really yeah
there was this uh what was the tom
cruise movie that they did the
soundtrack too
um they did a lot of soundtracks though
um and like game soundtracks as well but
they're done
yeah yeah so uh what kind of games
i wish i could do they've done they've
done 400 albums
risky business yeah they did the risky
business soundtrack which is like
probably one of their best albums um
yeah they're just they're literally just
three german dudes who uh play a lot of
like relaxing god damn they've got a
[ __ ] work out there they've got to
work here
um and then i guess nick drake is this
guy um
so nick drake is like
he so he's like kind of he plays folk
music
as if you couldn't tell from this
picture
um but he uh
he basically uh it's really hard to
describe him
so he he basically he killed himself
very early in his career okay um i think
he was like 23 24
um but he made this one album called
pink moon yeah and it's like it's
literally just him
and a guitar yeah that's it and it's
like super low-fi it's just it's just
him just like singing
just one guitar occasionally maybe like
a piano right but like it's so like it's
one of like
look like when it comes to like
depression
like as a theme in music yeah a lot of
artists have done it yeah from like all
sorts of different angles in my opinion
pink moon is probably the most [ __ ]
hard-hitting and like real album when it
comes to like depression and exploring
what makes you say that
it's because like it's not only just
like the tone of his singing
and just the fact that it's just him and
a guitar yeah but it's again it's like
lyrics obviously yeah um he has this one
song called um
uh i think it's called black dog um and
it inspired a book called black dog
where it's like depression is like a
black dog it just like keeps coming back
and like that's from the song that he
wrote um
but it's like i don't know it's like
it's beautiful but it's like
haunting it's like really really [ __ ]
haunting and like every time i play this
album like there's just like a couple of
songs that i just hit where i'm just
like breakdown crying i guess because
you know the you know what how yeah real
the stuff when someone's in that state
of mind you know sometimes
it's like you sometimes you can't always
express yourself or communicate that
emotion without having a medium like
music or some something like that like
what i can say is that like nick drake
is music but what it's certainly not is
entertainment
right it is old oh yes
it is
i would dare say it it really is the
awesome it is just like it is music in
its purest artistic form yeah where it's
like you don't put on a nick drake album
to [ __ ] jam out you put on a nick
drake album to like
self reflect and like you know just kind
of take it in yeah and like you know
kind of learn from it right because like
he was like he was super depressed like
i'm talking like mega mega mega
depressed from a child yeah and like i
mean i believe that yeah and uh you know
and like it led him to take his own life
you know he was like extremely [ __ ]
talented he probably had a bright future
ahead of him if he kept going but yeah
depression
yeah so he just kind of like gained a
cult status because of that and my
sister actually like put me onto nick
drake um because i guess she was in like
a stage in her life where she kind of
was like
yeah and i was like i feel like i found
him in like the perfect time and again
like this is not an artist i would
recommend to people who want bangers
like i feel like that type of music or
that type of media definitely has a
place because especially like when you
are in a dark place sometimes you're not
looking for like happy music or like
things to cheer you up but like
listening to
i guess someone who has been in that
same emotional state yeah or maybe
finding someone who you feel is in that
same emotional state as you yes there's
like a
comfort knowing that at least you're not
like the only one who's feeling like
yeah and when i was in that like
moment in my life as well and listening
to nick drake i think this album cheered
me up more than any [ __ ] album yeah
it's weird because when i'm really
depressed and really sad
listening to depressing music cheers me
up yeah like it's it's it's like
listening to happy music just makes me
more depressed yeah because i'm just
like how does how like why are they
happy and i'm not how dare this beat
like be this like upbeat and like happy
how dare these people be happy yeah you
listen to the pressing songs and i'm
just like [ __ ] man i'm not i'm not alone
i'm not the only one exactly yeah yeah
exactly yeah like that's the thing it's
like i feel listening to happy music
while depressed just does the opposite
effect because it makes you go how come
they're happy but i'm not yeah yeah you
know i can't relate to this happy mood
right now because that's not where i am
right now i'm in this [ __ ] dark
depressing like somber moment
and i need something that can like you
know compliment that feeling yeah um so
that's why i love nick drake um and then
yeah i talked about mf doom american
football uh so they're pretty much i
think they're a recent like addition to
like my favorite bands but uh they made
me fall in love with this genre of music
called midwest emo
what
what
there is a genre of music called midwest
emo you know people say genres out loud
yeah i just think you're just lying
like i just like you know like at this
point like
i feel like music most of all like
people just make up genres oh yeah of
course
it's music most of all yeah of course of
course they do they're just like it's
not punk it's it's just some derivative
of punk we don't want to be the same as
those punk bands so so what's so good
about the man okay so
it's emo
country no midwest midwest midwest
how would you define midwest midwestern
uh it is emo made by bands who have
lived in the midwest america so what is
the difference between midwest emo and
emo
okay so in terms of sound is there a
southern emote
i'm sure there is but i i wouldn't be
aware of it uh so midwest emo is like so
basically these guys founded the genre
um and like the indie scene for the past
like 20 years has been just filled with
midwest emo bands
um
yeah
and yeah they're like they're like
there's a lot of bands who have gotten
big off like band camp and like
soundcloud and like spotify and stuff
that are in this genre um and it's like
how do i explain midwest now it's like
it's like indie rock and math rock with
folk music
what is meth rock i see my god this is
what i don't understand math rock now
this is a problem because like every
time i
on itunes that thing am i stupid like it
is on itunes it probably is now but like
to me it's like are we categorizing
music too much
i mean i guess but that's because i feel
music just in general has expanded to so
yeah so far that like it's just like
it's kind of a shame to just throw it
all away as just rock
that's true i guess maybe this is just
my own inability to understand it and so
i'm just like why yeah well i mean you
know it's the same thing with like
electronic music right like you have
electronica you have house you have
trance you have yeah
where whereas like someone who doesn't
like music will be like it's just all
electronica it's just the beeps and the
boobs it's just the beeps and the boobs
right so it seems like so midwest emo is
like it's as the name suggests a lot of
the lyrical themes are very depressing
um but it's not like folk music like
strictly it's not like drake it's like
there's there's a band behind it usually
a lot of songs can be upbeat
but usually the lyrical contents are
very depressing hence the emo so that
makes it emo when it's depressing yeah
okay it's kind of like it's kind of like
emo
this is going to sound really bad it
midwest emo is like
is like nick drake if you were
privileged
[Laughter]
like like if you were like if you like i
don't know if that's a whole time if you
like
like so many layers right now it's like
midwest emo is like it's coming from
bands who like have lived in like the
midwest in small towns where like it's
not like they're born into like poverty
or like
yeah it's just like they kind of just
like lived in a town that's in the
middle of nowhere in the midwest not a
whole lot to do except get sad about
[ __ ] okay because they don't you know
because they have like because you're
from like minnesota
yeah yeah it is like suburban emo that's
the only way i just made that up it is
it is it is it is i just made a new
genre of music right now there's emo
rock yeah with mixes of folk music for
people who live in suburban midwest
areas i think i understand yeah
kind of took midwest emo sound and put a
little bit more of like a punk twist on
it yeah right so they're a little more
like upbeat right but they're still like
you know the lyrical context of like
paramore songs are still very much like
you know like i'm feeling depressed
because this girl doesn't like me and
she left me and you know it's like my my
town has nothing my friends have all
moved away that kind of stuff yeah yeah
so like so american football is that um
and through american football i found
like i like so you know how spotify has
that like spotify
yeah midwest email was number two for me
last year
um and like american football was like a
big reason for that wow because i just
listened to a lot of american football
like not just american football there's
like a lot of other like midwest emo and
i basically just found this like large
pool of midwest emo bands and they're
all [ __ ] amazing what appeals to you
about midwest emo
yeah
that's such a random like it is right
such a random genre of music it's um i
don't know
for one like the music is just good like
it sounds good um it's like performed
well like uh because it's like got
blends of math rock which is like very
like technical rock and like technical
guitar okay okay i just love that sound
in general like japan does a lot of
really good math rock like japan japan
has its own like branch of the top
called japanese math rock and like japan
is like really [ __ ] good at just like
you know like like okay
like
for instance right like the you know
like the opening psychopaths the first
time yeah yeah that's master
oh where it's like very technical guitar
and it's just like very like whaley fair
enough um but midwest emo kind of takes
a lot of that style of just like
technical guitar which just as a
guitarist i can appreciate for once like
like one thing i always want to know is
like how much do you appreciate
music in like a technical sense or like
a theory sense where oh obviously you're
like way more musical training musically
trained than you say i am um
so like how much does that play into
your taste in music or your appreciation
of music in general i mean you know if i
hear something i'm just like oh
what did he just do there then obviously
i'm gonna like poke my ears up right but
like i'm not gonna fall in love with a
band just because they're technical
right because again at the end of the
day if your music isn't good then it's
not good right and you know i've
listened to a lot of like midwest emo
and like even like metal like technical
metal bands and stuff like that where
i'm like yeah you're technical you are
skilled yeah but the music isn't really
for me kind of right right right um
yeah and then i guess finally is the
only japanese guy is maya dejun uh he
basically his name sounds familiar yeah
he wrote music for like clannad he also
wrote clan he also wrote aaron cannon
yeah and uh
angel b yeah basically every key so
basically what makes midajung is this
because you got into the gacha recently
that's true
what makes my degen my [ __ ] idol is
just again the fact that this man can
single-handedly write a story write
characters and just write all the music
for it just single-handedly it must be
an advantage though you can like
you know the characters in the story
better than anyone right you can craft
the whole what's but like i don't know
like
of course i like you know i i look up to
this guy just for like his ability to
like tell a story because like clannad
and like air and cannon and angel beats
are like you know great stories right
yeah um but like i think the one thing
that makes my like i appreciate my
attitude is just how [ __ ] musically
talented he is yeah because not only can
he write like somber like piano tracks
that have no lyrics at all like the
entirety of the clannad soundtrack yeah
make me cry like a [ __ ] yeah i cried
but he can write [ __ ] bangers as well
like you know any of the angel beats
songs
like absolute [ __ ] like girl's dead
monster that like that fictional band he
created in angel beats every song is a
[ __ ] banger i'm like you can write
bangers and you can make me cry it's
pretty impressive i didn't know that
like how do you do that i didn't know
that and so like you were talking about
the gotcha game i got into so key
recently released a gacha game called
heaven burns red which is the first
fully midadjun produced game in 15 years
um and so he wrote the story is it a
visual novel uh it's a it's yeah it's
kind of like it's very
dialogue-intensive because it's a
[ __ ] game yeah um
but it's also like it's like a
turn-based rpg kind of thing as well
okay of course it has gotcha so of
course you know
yeah so he wrote the story he wrote the
character designs he came up with the
character designs he came up with a
scenario and he wrote all the music for
[ __ ] well that's why he hasn't been
doing anime recently hasn't it exactly
all this time in uh i mean it's also
because he's been like extremely sick
yeah as well oh man like the whole like
you know the whole theme in like angel
beats about like the hard thing that's
just based off his own life oh jesus
christ yeah because he has like a
chronic like heart uh like a disease or
something he's done so much yeah yeah
i mean he wrote i'm pretty sure i don't
know if this is true but i think he
wrote angel beats in the hospital bed
seriously yeah while he was admitted to
hospital he wrote angel what the [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] bam and it's just yeah
and he's just like he's a banff like and
the fact that like
again like this man doesn't miss
not just like
even in the new game like the story is
great the characters are great and the
music [ __ ] slaps so i guess i guess
everything else just lifts your
enjoyment of the music more right and
it's like and i feel like you know you
know we were saying earlier that like
fully coolly as well like pillows i was
i was very close to putting pillows
because that's just like pinches it out
for you yeah i think mitogen just
pinches it out for me because like as
much as i love the fully cooling
soundtrack the first soundtrack that
made me fall in love with anime
soundtracks was kleiner
because like again as a pianist myself
listening to like piano music that makes
me [ __ ] break down crying like go
perform it
and it's like i can't even i can't even
like learn to play these songs without
crying right right and it's like that's
that's wholesome and that's like really
hard to do as someone who like you know
because there's someone who writes music
i strive to do that to people right and
the fact that this guy can do it over
and over and over again with like
everything he also writes is like how do
you do that why can't one man have all
that talent okay it's not fair i'm just
saying dude he would not be where they
are without this guy hey sometimes you
see someone and you're like you're a bit
too talented
this is unfair and you're good looking
like yeah yeah as if i couldn't like
like
give me something to hate like god
obviously didn't love all humans equally
because
he made you he paid my attention
it's not fair it's not fair i i wish i
had a sliver of the talent this guy has
yeah damn but uh yeah i guess that's my
three by three i was very uh i feel like
i learned a lot yeah i learned i learned
way more than me talking myself or
listening to economics i don't know man
i i feel a little bit uh pushed back
because i was like i need to somehow top
gaunt living in anime backstory you
can't you can't top that i couldn't top
it so i was like the slumdog millionaire
we're just we're just living in god's
life this is we're not we're not
god's
like six bands but i never had a cool
story like i just i just i thought when
i said i was in a band everyone had a
similar experience
no no you're wrong
what what happened what normally happens
when you're in a band then do you not
kind of like
pretend yeah yeah you go to the
drummer's house you play a couple of
cover songs that's it and then you're
like alright cool see you never again
yeah that happens all the time yeah
smash mouth once yeah what's the point
of forming a band if you're not going to
play gigs
how are you going to play a gig how you
going to arrange that
[ __ ] dumb as [ __ ] how did you get how
did you get a gig that's [ __ ] easy in
brighton there's so many oh yeah in
brighton yeah yeah in sydney it's pretty
[ __ ] difficult because there's no
whales this is fields
what are they going to sing smash mouth
too
where am i going to sing all star god
think about this there's like five gigs
going on every weekend and brian so i
guess i didn't take that i can't even
top you when it comes to like band names
either because like that band name is
just like [ __ ] like the best band name i
was in was resting [ __ ] face
but that's just because the lead singer
had a resting [ __ ] it's always like
that it's like cheeto puffs why it's
called chew i always like it yeah it's
gonna bite us in the ass in 10 years and
we have copyright infringement yeah yeah
exactly we'll just deal with it but damn
i guess that was our trash taste in
music yeah let us know down below what
you thought about it who has the
trashiest taste in mind
thank you very much i appreciate that
probably like i i i had a hard time
explaining why i liked my music no you
did not what you [ __ ] wanted
you had the longest thing you literally
had amazing stories for everything i i
literally just like i did like the thing
is i didn't even talk about the music
that doesn't matter yeah but you had
like a kishimoto filler artwork for
stories for every single baby
with that yeah all right well you know
who doesn't miss us with that [ __ ] the
patrons hell yeah
this guy has great tasting music
all of these guys have amazing taste in
music yeah absolutely cracking tasty
music but hey if you like to support the
show then go up to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us some memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify we're going to make a new we're
going to make a new genre of music right
now we're going to call it trash called
fun yeah
we've caught chat i came up with
put that on the wiki
coined the term weeb call
alright see you guys next time see you
guys later bye
[Music]
you